[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yes yes
you know i'm so first of all welcome
everybody welcome back hassan
we're back it's nice to see you again
after a a hiatus we're back
yeah i'm so glad you know it's a
white-pilled day kind of huh yeah no
this is a great day it's a great day for
politics um
i have to inform you that um i have uh i
fought jeff
i went to his house with a baseball bat
and i was like you cannot take over my
spot
i don't like that well it's up to the
people
my bestie is out of my hands if you want
to take a poll right now no it was it
was unacceptable i saw how beautiful his
hair looked on the podcast yeah i did
not like that pecker is mad i did not
like that at all he is a handsome man he
gives he'll give any hunk
any heartthrob a run for there he's a
very handsome man yeah and you had it
was like you had jeff on
who was like the looks and then you had
mike who was like constantly talking
about politics right it's just
what's going on no it's not what it
looks like yeah leftovers i'm the one
who's left over no no no i'm out there
i'm like squidward watching spongebob
and patrick have fun never never
we could never replace you i want you to
know right now jeff may be more handsome
mike might be more determined yeah mike
might have better political takes than i
do but but you are hassan don't you
understand that i do i could never
replace you you himbo
you beautiful himbo
can we do the show like this it's just i
like this
oh yeah
by the way i just want to say at the top
of the show you know that huge uh bill
got passed um
the uh inflation reduction act and it
was super nice that they earmarked
another 20 billion for us for our studio
defenses
yeah you know
that's the 50 billion dollars bipartisan
compromise when it comes to the
important things you know what i mean
funding the police uh giving them more
money and apcs uh
and also our our facility yeah i'm just
so happy because i've been really
wanting like um a.i
you know robot wars warfare robots to
control the perimeter which we'll be
able to get now
yeah friend of the show i did a thing um
came all the way out from australia to
to put a strap a machine gun on on a dog
i don't know if you saw that
uh we have those now
he's been doing a robot dogs yeah he got
a boss dynamics robot from michael
reeves and strapped a [ __ ]
strap the mp5 onto it not a 50 cal he
should never have done that this is the
worst [ __ ] my goal yeah i've seen it but
yeah we actually i mean the the point
was he was making political commentary
about how dangerous guns are they're
they're they're good they're good boys
no i'm saying this just uh
this is like the beginning of half-life
oh yeah but this has been done already
too anyway the point is basically that
we've put in an order for like a
thousand of these yeah don't even try
yeah don't even don't even come near us
we got that and and they're so much
better than the one he's been working on
it they're better than the one in the
video no way better yeah
but we still have the bad ones too just
to spray indiscriminately at people yeah
yeah yeah
so um anyway listen
i understand your feelings got hurt let
me see what you you had some remarks to
say about that let's pull it up um
leftovers is not happening tomorrow by
the way because somebody decided to cut
me out
by the way what happened was
we we filmed on
wednesday
with tano mike and jeff they didn't want
to go they don't want to do it live
yeah if you can believe that i can
believe it
and so we had to edit it and throw it up
on thursday
so i really i did it for you because if
we double posted
nobody would have watched wow oh that's
so much worse wow just being honest wow
i didn't want to i didn't want to
embarrass the leftovers
then i would have been then it would
have been like a direct comparison like
people would be like oh jeffy the hotter
one like he's definitely he's got it
like that because i mean that episode
has 1.5 million i mean you know
don't our episodes get like about i
don't even know yeah we're streaming
though to be fair well it's only like
five days it's gonna it's gonna do
really well yeah we get like a million
dude pounded for that
pretty good right political [ __ ]
podcast i think so
i think so for corrupting the youth's
mind with uh communism
brad dead yeah with dark brandon i mean
that's why he gave us 20 billion dollars
to be honest because like we have been
pushing the dark brandon agenda pretty
hard oh i love that that the libs have
reclaimed dark brandon meme i know but
like i'm very conflicted on that because
on the one hand dude there's so much to
tell i know i've got all crowders we
have so much to talk about ethan there's
so much has happened like maybe we
should just skip them [ __ ] and memes
and just get into it because there's no
way we're going to get through here let
me actually let me watch this because
you know i don't have a stream after i i
have a
tv show that i'm filming with austin uh
g4
no no it's nice g4 it's a austin show uh
name your price
so i have to do that later so that's why
we can go like a little bit over there
oh we can't we don't have to end it
exactly at 12 is what i'm saying
what is this show uh it's on tv
uh it's on g4 and what is that engine
tv show like olivia munn remember movie
yeah i think so yeah okay why are you
flexing on me well i it originally is
just filmed on austin's channel though
on twitch so like
i think it makes it the tv if unless i
make a lot of 911 jokes in which case
you get it from circulation which is
[ __ ] up yeah don't say anything about
bombing any sort of yeah
i didn't finish the sentence i'm just
saying don't say that talking about love
bombing anyway in any case okay no no no
i was talking about explosives oh
[Laughter]
but i didn't finish my sentence so it
should be fine i said don't talk about
it and certainly don't obviously
advocate for it obviously i would never
i would never do that yeah i believe an
individual citizen also in this country
has a right to own a nuclear warhead
warhead that's fine though that's a
normal take ah i don't know why people
would ever look at that and by the way
hassan if you're going to be on tv just
steer clear of any mention of den dan
crenshaw's eye hole yeah i would not i
would never do that thank you i would
never do that i would never bring that
up well let's just see where this goes
because i i kind of like to see i like
to see you guys all fight fight over me
somebody decided to cut me out
and instead
uh you know
do a super secret special podcast
episode
with someone who's hotter than me what's
up yeah because i don't have [ __ ]
lower than 10 body fat like it is like
jeff does is that what's going on dude
huh yeah shots fired
i'm out here wearing [ __ ] teddy fresh
all goddamn days i know you know what
[ __ ] that's so true jeff never wore
teddy fridge that's right dude and [ __ ]
jeff dude you're my new bestie yeah
jeff's no longer my bestie
he's never worn teddy fresh chef's gonna
come out wearing teddy fresh and then
you're like hassan you're done you're
out you're [ __ ] out dude
that would that would definitely push
the needle for me but
until then you love it look at look at
your face
uh so so but you know
okay that's good we could go a little
bit long
um
i there's something i want to show at
the top of the uh this top of the show
obviously
um our news correspondent uh our new
news who is hotter okay so okay well
it's leftovers this doesn't count
i don't know man
that's pretty commanding
okay that makes me feel good more of
that everybody
yeah there you go you see that makes me
feel really good we all get we all feel
good yeah
yeah
okay now do one with me hassan and jeff
and be honest you got it
i'm looking for that five percent yeah
i mean i don't know i we'll see no no no
i'm serious i want it to be really low
for me
no no no everyone knows i'm a beast
and don't don't vote for me at a pity
i'm serious
don't be like oh he's i want to make him
feel better because he says he's peace
don't worry i'm fine i feel confident he
wants to vote for out of pity he's
saying don't do it no psychology i just
think it's funny if i get like two votes
i'm fine with that
but as the votes populate here hassan
this is important um
we have a new news correspondent uh-huh
uh biden looks lost appears ready for a
handshake but he's already received it
so
this comes from our good friend
arab world news no way
let's see
now our great speaker our partner who
all of these bills we've met
oh my god look look look at his face
though the funniest part about this is
like okay interesting oh oh joe forgot
he got the first handshake yeah that's
pretty bad no but i mean that's right
but the funniest part about that is that
he goes you son of a [ __ ] like
then he goes ah i see how it is
this guy has a five second memory hole
what's going on here
wait let me see this again because arab
world news is bringing some
joe
joe come on all right well let's hear
his analysis
again we just watched now by the looks
lost and appears ready for
handshake already received by the
waiting
hand shake from
senate chuck schumer yeah and chuck
schumer is seeing
shaking hands with biden and
three others
then he walks back to the bedroom
by then
wave his hand to right hand with shaq
schumer again
during speeches
as this video circulating in our own
internet yeah and social media i want to
say honestly this video
is not a real someone oh is that right
for his uh this video wait how is it not
real
is it is it fake news miss information
destroying miss info because i i
actually was worried for a brand in
there for a minute
but
how was how did he fake that it looked
real [ __ ] i mean
oh he's got the scoop too because
according to snopes it's unproven it's
still up in the yeah i was about to say
i was about to say
you know even snopes is hitting him with
the unproven and those guys are libs so
yeah i believe arab world news this guy
i don't know sky news australia covered
it as though it actually happened can
you okay uh can you show that clip
because go down dan
this is from washington times opinion
well there that's yeah that's that's not
a not exactly a reputable source for
sure rnc
no
but let's let's let's watch this closely
now this is important
okay
goes back
now our great speaker our partner who
always that's [ __ ] fake bro
look at his face it looks like someone's
super implanted
[Music]
interesting we'll have to send this to
the lab or lab here in our million
dollars i don't know
but this is literally an arab news world
scoop if that is the case yeah that's
breaking news he broke this um two days
ago actually
wow
that's crazy that's actually crazy
snopes they're they're ahead of snopes
on this one dude that's our boy he's out
there arab world news shout out wait
wait what is why he says it's uh it's
fake okay
then
watch also the real video
what
excuse me
um
this video is fake oh he's saying this
video is fake
yeah okay we know that i'm sorry well it
has cuts in it yeah
right maybe was he talking about this
video being fake and now the previous
one
no
no maybe no no no no
you've seen the previous video he's
saying the previous video is fake he's
saying this is evidence
but this one has cuts in it dude so it's
a little this is a little bit that's
that's a we'll have him we'll let him
have that w though
i think he's right if you scoop the
previous one
[Applause]
hear all the noise out there
we know there are those who focus more
on seeking power yeah and secure in the
future excuse me
and securing the future
in the ending of the video don't forget
support me by like and comment thank you
yeah of course and i did like it but
i'll leave a comment
and
i knew this was fake
thank you bro
for spreading the truth
we love you anything you want to add
i'm good that's perfect yeah okay so
so shout out i mean he's the best arab
world news
friend of the show actually yeah yeah i
did make contact with him actually and
um
we may we may have an
appearance on the show sometime in the
future here oh hell yeah yeah we
yeah we made contact he said he's too
shy at the moment to call in live
because his english isn't good enough
but it's all good he was very gracious
about it though that he was going to
work on his english and he would hope to
uh to come on soon so friend speaking of
friends of the show
ninja cotton candy g fuel that's
that's all you know we call him here
hey you know whose flavor
cotton candy used to be keemstars yeah
no way that's so funny oh you didn't
know about this arc this character
ninja came out with the cotton candy
flavor a few months ago
and keemstar had a meltdown he's like
bro you should have asked me for
permission before you dropped that what
does he think he owns the ip around
cotton candy he does he actually does
that's insane hussain hussain who's
saying i don't know how to say her name
yeah so anyway uh hassan is upset i'm
sorry hassan we are besties are you a
ninja no i have no issues with ninjas no
not ninja i mean i'm just recapping
um
here is mike praising you though and
this gave me pause because mike is one
of my new best friends and yeah see oh
i'm hotter than jeff no i'm not stop it
but you still crushed me
obviously he i think i think you are
hotter than jack i wanted i think we're
both hotter than jeff now
i was hoping it'd be like two percent
all right whatever get it it's not funny
yeah we're against i think i think
we are um
you know you guys are building bridges
and i didn't even realize that a bridge
was there to build with me and me and
big mike he's a good guy um he had some
nice things to say about my andrew tate
debate on the impulsive podcast he's a
good man that that mic in fact you know
what what you know what's wrong with
impulsive i would say at this point too
much um logan paul
i think if we could just
turn up the mic turn down the logan that
would probably be a hit podcast
i don't want to say that because i think
i'm going to be on their podcast soon so
i'm going to go ahead and say
no i think it's just enough logan paul
on there
that'd be great for you to go on there
yeah yeah he's a good guy he's changed
you know he's a new man dick just don't
mention ding donk okay
oh yeah that's true the nfd stuff is
just oh my god
but i do there are things that i do
respect about the pulse i've said it
before um and this is not because i may
or may not be going on the impulsive
podcast
um
that uh i mean i i respect that they
have you know trained a lot jake paul is
even oh yeah i have i have like actual
yeah i have actual mix martial artist
friends who are trainers uh who who
respect his uh dedication and effort i
like that logan paul's also doing the
wwe thing
pursue your passions absolutely unless
it's like you know
doing pranks and stuff in which case
don't if your passion is you know dink
toink or pranks then don't do that and
pursue the wrestling thing instead play
the theme song just because it's very it
is passionate you're my favorite that's
logan paul
and that's passion hassan
i'm just saying
you're my favorite oh my god there's a
lot of heart now
oh my goodness
all right let's cut i don't want to kill
hassan's chance for it
you're you're killing me no i don't
before you kill my chances i'm dead now
we're not going to ruin this for hassan
all right let's see what he had to say
did a a relatively good job with him and
i think oh this is cool i wonder what
he's trying to promote here
i like god i think those guys dm'd me
is that what is that like their energy
drink or something it's like him in ksi
yeah
yeah they were like yo
love to send you like crates or
something i was like i don't know what
the [ __ ] this is
what is it is it a water horse drink
like a gatorade thing
okay i haven't tried it but
it's out there i gotta do a taste test
we've been it's kind of hard to get
right at this moment i mean i i would do
a taste test yeah because they're
[ __ ] sending meat crates that's why
apparently there's any influences free
ones apparently it's doing very well but
you know not surprising i love how his
hoodies just like
there's no [ __ ] branding color bottle
it's just prime
black and white yeah well he knows
he knows uh he knows how to do it again
oh wait hold on cameron you've tried a
prime yeah i had the blue one okay what
did you think it was pretty good i
didn't hate it i loved it actually let's
go cameron yeah yes
yeah it's great and and how delicious we
love prime
iron delicious beverages okay no i would
never want you to lie to me and um how
does it compare to like drink like
gatorade
uh i think it's better than gatorade to
be honest yeah yeah
gatorade is gatorade is down to be
honest gatorade has been dropping the
ball it's too salty and it's too sweet
yeah he's been awfully quiet since prime
dropped that's true yeah that's what i
was thinking go ahead cameron i'm gonna
stop shilling now i don't [ __ ] care i
mean i like prime it it tastes more
natural and it's pretty good and i'm not
even bullshitting i liked it when i had
it you heard it you heard it from
cameron folks okay
quick gatorade question for you and this
is very controversial in my community
sure it's not known for controversies
for any other reason um do you think you
can fit a gatorade in jan crenshaw's eye
hole
that's not what i was gonna say but
probably um so
i am i'm an advocate for warm gatorade
room temperature gatorade room
temperature
i'm a room temp gatorade fan i think it
like brings out the flavor better do you
even think i think ice cold gatorade
tastes different
than room temp gatorade i prefer it i
never thought of that before but i'm
with you on 100 how are you going to
back them up you never even tried it no
i know i've had it but i just never put
two and two together so do you like
microwave your gatorade what are you
doing to get out no i just don't put it
in the fridge oh so you're talking about
room temperature yeah room temp gator oh
that's not farm gatorade but hot
gatorade well
you just that's just i don't know you're
right i shouldn't have said that
are you saying you like it better hassan
are you just saying it's different i
prefer room temperature gatorade i do
ice cold gatorade they do have a
different taste i think it depends on
the flavor too though to be honest with
you sure you can't just change it up
willy-nilly like that because warm red
gatorade is
dog [ __ ] yeah
red i don't like i'm not a big fan of
red anyway i'm not a big red guy i'm a
blue guy all the way
i'll be white too white's really good i
don't know what that one is you're
bringing the uh polarization to our
community because our whole chat's like
50 50 on that i don't have strong
opinions about gatorade to be honest but
room temp is fine with me caught threw
me off but every time i drink gatorade
recently
it's so [ __ ] salty and sweet it's
like putrid man i can't [ __ ] with it
when i was a kid i hit that [ __ ] all the
time i only drink zeros anyway so oh
zero same good yeah
good
um i got time to add calories for for
gatorade you know
how'd you what's your body fat at
i don't know i have no idea but it's not
too high it's not yeah it's not no of
course it's not low enough i've uh
on my weight loss journey i'm at 252
pounds is the lowest i hit this week
um
which is really good because i started
off at like 285 when we were doing
leftovers like around last year when i
first started losing weight and like
training again you lost 30 pounds since
we started so far yeah
and
there's a lot of recomp in the first
half of the year where i was like
building muscle mass again
but i'm not at um i'm trying to hit like
once i start hitting like 240 i'll start
posting shirtless photos okay that's
what we're all waiting for
yeah shirtless ladies and gentlemen and
then the goal is to hit 2 30.
and uh eventually only fans right
no oh come on bro i'll do a hot tub
stream before i do only fans i'll
probably right there just get your feet
wet sodas yeah yeah would you show your
dick on uh
on only fans for a million bucks a month
no no not for money like it's for for
free for clout
like i i think the i mean i don't i
don't need to make more money right um i
make enough of it as it is
but
i don't know i just i have body
dysmorphia it's hard for me to do only
fans i talked about this on my on my
podcast with uh eva elfie
you know who that is i saw that clip
yeah yeah
and there they were like why don't you
do only fans i was like i i have too
much body dysmorphia to be able to do it
right right like it takes a lot
wait what's the only fans lawsuit dan
only fan oh can this be true i saw this
i was like no [ __ ] way only fans
bribed meta to put thousands of porn
stars on a terror watch list
there's no [ __ ] way that's true right
i don't know
because that would that would require
meta which is facebook
and
only fans to be so corrupt to make this
happen right well it's not alleging uh
meta
itself but specific employees at meta
like they bribed individuals that worked
there and and what's the advantage to
putting porn stars on a terror watch
well it's ones that weren't on only fans
that were on like competitors websites
and and this is all just a ledge by the
way again what's the benefit of doing
that other than
drive out competition from other you
know subscription
adult websites like only fans yeah but
how does putting them on a terror watch
do that because their posts would get
flagged and removed
what i also don't understand is like
they already [ __ ] blacklist most porn
this shadow band porn stars there's a
porn star shadow band on all meta
platforms anyway oh meta yeah yeah so i
don't understand what only fans was
doing there oh you're talking about
their facebook groups get like
terrorists tagged yeah or their
instagram page or stuff like that
this is that's kind of wild this is what
the lawsuit no no accusing them of yeah
hassan did a very good job with him by
uh
by by debating him using facts and
statistics
can you say what some of his takes are
yeah i mean he has takes on women
driving and he he has any access i think
that's all they said right yeah then he
just like uh talks about the debate
itself like he just like describes it
and how i owned him and stuff but yeah i
know he was it was a good nice little
shout out mike great guy man yeah shout
out to mike
shout out my friend that's a good dude
right there man
yeah that's it i mean entertain is so
bad even [ __ ] jake paul looks good in
consideration yeah yeah the jake had
this rare w i think i know what he's
doing though because jake did this whole
thing about like [ __ ] andrew tate and
i'm pretty sure he's just trying to bait
him for a fight
because i was like why don't you fight
him
i think jake just wants to fight with
whoever would watch it i think for sure
he would
here's the thing
i was like why is jake saying this he is
like
more in the tate zone than not probably
like philosophically
oh yeah and so i think he's trying to
bait him but here it is it's funny that
the top g is a fanboy he runs with this
whole thing like what color is your
bugatti andrew like
it's not cool to tell kids that they
need a bugatti to be cool andrew tate's
fans
[ __ ] jig that's pretty funny jake
paul saying that is so funny yeah the
dude literally made a song called all i
want for christmas is by jake paul merch
remember that yeah but that's different
because like you do get [ __ ] with that
that's true that's yeah that's like are
you kidding me dude when i was
when i was 20 years old dude and i was
rocking my jake paul merch no i'm
kidding i'm not even going to make that
[ __ ] ted it's like we're broaching
keemstar territory keemstar is like
listening in he's like yeah no that's
what i did actually that's how i found
all of my girlfriends i mean he's still
rocking his team 10 [ __ ] at this moment
that's how he pulled his current one i
don't even does jake also have like a
young audience i feel like he's old now
but he doesn't make content right he
just fights people now yeah he just
fights people directly i mean
they're all virgins and they're watching
him to try to get laid but they're gonna
get spit on and slapped by a girl that's
what's gonna happen
okay i mean he's right obviously so
but i think andrew tate is actually
already fading his star is already
fading i think everybody is over him
and he's his disappearing phase has
already begun dude my man did one
[ __ ] debate where there was a little
bit of pushback and he just fell off the
map it is wild i don't know how the [ __ ]
that happened
like
was
it seemed like i mean it's it's
plateauing like as of as of that debate
it has started to plateau like it hit
the peak
i feel that you can directly take credit
for his demise
i mean i get i give this to you i'm
trying to i'm trying to have another
conversation with him to dive a little
bit deeper into his businesses but i
don't know if he's down to do that
anymore i think he's like
he's already too busy like doing
shows with his brother talking about how
i'm uh bisexual
is that right yeah he said i'm a
bisexual armenian genocide wait are you
bisexual not that i am not that because
that was just news to me no i am i am a
heterosexual man
and also i do not deny the armenian
genocide oh yeah yeah are you sure
because i don't know i saw andrew tate
say that you do well he is a he is a
very credible uh narrator so
well by the way here so you can see
here's his google trends it's dipping
[ __ ] your time is up you little [ __ ]
watch this [ __ ] dip down i mean we'll
see
he just uh well he positioned himself
for that he was literally like well now
we're entering the second phase of my
bugatti water
uh plan
with the wall room
anyway we don't have to do another
[ __ ] episode on anything man i know i
we've covered it endlessly i'm sure your
fans are also
well i've just tapped that thing on his
on his proverbial graph a little bit
someone told me that he went from 100k
on uh hustlers university to 60k though
that that doesn't surprise me i mean i
don't know what the [ __ ] are they
getting out of that i mean i could also
see that being like uh just a cut
of uh all the bots or something like
maybe discord was like yeah there's a
lot of bots in this server we should
oh the discord got cold i mean i don't
know we'll i i just i've never been a
believer that he had a hundred thousand
active paying you know 50 a month paying
people in this in this community very
yeah that's very doubtful but you know
the other thing we've got to hold your
feet to the fire a little bit here today
because
you've been claiming
that you have a normal sized head you're
just claiming oh here we go for years
and years obviously years and years and
years and um
here just from the last step we did i'm
all ahead and it's a lie and we're here
to address the lies folks well i have to
push it to your body
i have to pee real quick before we do
that we'll get ready okay get the
calipers bust out the calipers yeah so
hassan has
we're gonna put this to the to the grave
once and for all hassan insists that he
has a normal sized head
uh there's the meme of course that he
has a tiny head and so what we have
purchased in preparation is a dome
measuring
uh calper
yes sir
and so what we're going to be doing
today is a head to shoulder ratio we're
going to take the measurement of the
head
and the shoulder divide shoulder by head
and see
you know
where we sit on the percentage you want
to do you so we can compare sure yeah
let's do it let's do me so you're gonna
do so how does this work you do like the
thickest part exactly okay
so
so ladies and gentlemen dan is um
he
is placing the calpers
carefully carefully
very carefully
all right olivia
okay
they're spiky
okay
okay what are we at almost almost
exactly six ow six inches
six inches
that's what she said
okay now let's get the shoulders
out what are we gonna do about this
[Music]
go ahead now i don't think i have a
large head in general
i think i have
uh probably
a 22 inches
okay so hassan i'm s i've got six inches
now does it matter the front or you know
what i mean
i don't even know how to calculate that
because i mean yeah
he's like this is not even real skull
science i don't even know how to do the
real one
so is it is it better to have a big dome
is that the skull science for the record
i don't even know i don't know what it
is the only phonology i believe in is
cop phranology i believe in a concept
called cop skull
that um you know you're a signed cop at
birth
okay
uh and and you know you can
you can overcome it and some people do
not many do
um but uh that's the reason why they
look so thumb like all costs okay that's
interesting now hold on now so i was six
inches by me with the calipers first are
you gonna tell me my shoulders
what's my head to shoulder ratio
six to 32.
you have 22 22.
32 20. i mean 22. 22 divided by 6. 6
divided by 22. divided by 22. no
uh 0.7 repeated
so
so
okay
and so i've got
[Music]
0.7 is that like 70 is that right 2-7
0.27
okay so my head is 27 the length of my
shoulders
okay hassan now the moment of truth i'm
i'm legitimately tense right you've
never done this so this could be a
this could be a defining moment for you
the thing is you do have very broad
shoulders so this
that's the other that's the whole idea
right yeah touching
there's
so much more hair padding than i
expected yeah get it down
it's literally
[Laughter]
that's how you know it's good he's doing
the same to me
oh
just a tiny fraction under six as well
so actually wait yes whoa you do have a
tiny head wait really
but his shoulders are way wider well
that's that that was the point my point
is that no our domes are the same my
point is that my head is a normal sized
head except for the fact that my
shoulders are you can't say it's normal
size when you're like six four i mean
what is normal size what do you think
like
do you think skulls [ __ ] uh well it
scales with your body no
no 29 it doesn't for the win you think
andre the giant had like a [ __ ] six
inch wide dome i mean i guess maybe i
don't know maybe
well okay so mine was 27
yes are we doing exactly
six for this one are we doing 5.9 yeah
just yeah
29.
20
or if we round up 21.
21
head to shoulder and what was mine
22.
my i know i know my shoulders are
brought i think i have a normal sized
head and my shoulders are broad you do
have very broad shoulders but i gotta
say
small head mean proven no it has not
okay
god we have proven it here today
what if you have what if you what if
your head is is looking big for your
shoulders what about that i think you're
you've got a lot of length here because
this hat fits me fine i have a small i
think i have a smaller head usually but
i think we've got to measure front to
back like maybe you want to try that
just to redeem him a little bit
you wouldn't do front to back uh
measurement i mean maybe just
you just you yeah just just to redeem
him i don't want him to feel bad about
having a tiny head or anything
jesus christ
you have it all what is the what is the
normal percentage i wonder uh like
what's the we are literally doing like
in cell science right now like we are
doing for knowledge this is important
don't don't discount
absolutely so we're gonna get a front to
back measurement of sauna i think this
is where you're gonna shine
i don't know this this this is where
you're gonna shine
yeah dig that in there dan
he's digging it
we have uh
seven inches in
87 128
you gotta be seven
87th 128th what the [ __ ] does that even
mean number wise what is that
we should reduce this fraction a little
bit i mean let's see that's about okay
that's yeah i mean that's almost eight
inches
damn
bro you pack it eight inches yeah i'm
packing eight inches front to back all
right see i don't think i'm gonna show
as uh impressively
go ahead at the thickest part please
don't hit him on the thickest part the
thickest part of the shaft please okay
there's an interesting variant here wait
you didn't what is it
here's the thing
you have a very you have a very sloped
forehead i'm realizing ethan what the
[ __ ] you trying to say i'm just it's
kind of neanderthal shape
just a little bit there's no way to do
that helpers and not not
you can't get the full comfort the
circumference there's no way there's no
way to hit this without here
how about
just ow damn bro
trying to lobotomize me no he he he did
he did that too trying to get brain
matter out of him why is that so sharp
it is it is dangerously sharp you could
meant for automotive [ __ ] i'm pretty
sure oh that does those don't have
feelings so just because the nasal
culture came for
give it all science
give it a little extra uh
give it a little extra to compensate for
my as you call pro magnum
uh no because you're squishing it you
got to give me a little extra girth yeah
there you go all right wait it's slant
either you give me extra girls
digging into my forehead you have a very
oddly shaped forehead
just be precise okay because this is
important science
[Music]
yeah you're gonna have to pull it out a
little bit what the [ __ ] what i've
look at this screen what are you doing
right now oh my god i don't know what
you mean
it looks normal to me now i got ethan
hands seven and a half so so you got a i
have a mighty a mighty length on your i
have a i have a longer dome than you do
i guess damn you packing eight inches
dog
nice seven and a half is pretty good too
what do you mean you're right no that's
a that's a hog
can you make my hands bigger please
yeah i'll
we don't have the technology yet we can
develop that though oh no we can put our
our top what if i hold it all here would
that help
i'll get in the lab i'll try i don't
know if it's possible all right forget
it
okay
how do we feel now that we've measured
the dome
um my insecure i have a newfound
insecurity now
but then no i'm kidding i don't give a
[ __ ] i feel like the takeaway is
actually that
i feel like we debunked the small
headlights did we yeah because you guys
have almost the same size head it's all
about the ratio though as you said okay
but i would think that hassan's head
would be bigger than mine right i mean
technically it is bigger than yours it's
just not like it is it is bigger wider
than yours so it's about the same here
and it's a little long it's a half inch
longer on the
back yeah life is a game of inches ethan
i mean that's that's where it counts you
know what i mean
hi i'm dick tip okay we'll let the
people interpret it as they i mean
people are going to continue with the
matter regardless which is fine i mean
it's it's funny i have small hands
you've got a small dome
yeah i um
but i i've always known that i have uh
you know a very
i don't know i've never been insecure
about that ever this is i have broad
shoulders
it's just a gag i think nobody actually
thinks that
you're a beautiful man thank you okay i
need to hear that you hear that jeff
he's calling me beautiful definitely not
you okay jeff's a beast
but he has a perfectly
sized head for his perfect body you
don't know that he's got a lot of hair
it might be big it might be he's got a
big head which you don't want that
either
really i feel like having a bigger head
is better right isn't that what like
actors have well i guess not because
sebastian gorga has a gigantic dome and
he looks like [ __ ] i'll be honest i've
seen dudes with like people women and
men sometimes gonna have massive heads
it's a little bit it's intimidating it's
a lot to do it's a lot to take in yeah
you're like what i can't look at your
entire face at once like what's
happening you're like
yeah there's like a whole race of people
i feel like that are like just
big-headed yeah there's like a different
thing going on there
but let's get on let's move on with the
show we've already wasted
well i won't say wasted but 20 minutes
already folks oh way more than that yeah
it's almost 11 40 minutes oh 40 whoops
we don't have ads today do we
uh
no
they're stealing it
all right so let's talk about what we're
all super excited to get to today
trump got raided we love it
and i'm gentlemen we got him we can i
just say uh i want to give a quick shout
out to the boys in the blue our law
enforcement community our officers our
leos the u.s postal service blue lives
matter blue lives matter thin blue line
nobody's ever talking about what happens
to cops out there it's really hard to be
running around when you're
you know when you got heart disease
thank you thank you thank you thank you
i want to fund the fbi further fund the
fbi that's right
that's right
we love our we love our law enforcement
folks
you know who doesn't
but marjorie taylor green yo that that
woman is such a [ __ ] beast man yeah
they are i mean here i'll pull this so
much to say about this
marjorie taylor green she's just such a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] i mean that goes
hard though you know
first of all
it's the shameless grifting for me
um it's like she didn't waste a second
to try to fundraise off this defund the
fbi
how is that even a real thing you want
to defund the entire fbi i'm [ __ ] so
on board like it'd be great [ __ ] it who
cares fbi do something useful they do
definitely yeah even even better like
all federal so even ice uh to a certain
degree has like a like a sex trafficking
division and kidnapping division so like
no matter which federal agency you're
talking about of course there's gonna be
like
like a fraction of the resources you're
gonna go to like combating real crimes
and [ __ ] and of course the fbi does uh
uh decent work in
uh in in that field as well but over in
an overwhelming sea of incompetence
um so i feel like
of all the uh governmental law
enforcement bodies i feel like the fbi
is the most legit
i mean there's a lot of federal crimes
like money laundering stuff financial
crimes [ __ ] like that is all being
investigate investigated by the fbi i
just wish they did more of that like
that's i i'm in agreement what is it
they're doing that you don't like
besides raiding trump so
no i love that i don't know that was
great [ __ ] awesome um that more of
that please and also rape throw hillary
clinton in there throw hillary clinton
in the pile you know what i mean i'm not
they were such a centrist on that well
hold on they were investigating her yeah
they did throw that she was already in
the pilot i know but they couldn't
arrest her so that didn't steal
classified document yeah well again you
know make it work i'm just saying make
it work christopher wray your [ __ ]
fake friend you got appointed by donald
trump that they say that doesn't matter
yeah yeah i know um yes so so what is it
that the fbi does that you don't oh okay
so one of the things that they well
first of all the fbi historically uh is
started off as a white supremacist
institution
the original the inception of the fbi is
quite literally around like the white
woman trafficking act and like uh
basically trying to use a federal
authority a federal agency to to combat
black people consensually having uh
interracial relationships with white
women uh the the famous boxer that was
exonerated by trump actually like post
posthumously pardoned by trump is a is
one of the first uh examples of that so
it
it has its roots in in white supremacy
obviously but uh even in contemporaries
i mean they
played a role in the execution they
literally executed fred hampton
uh and and numerous other uh black
leaders um
obviously uh tried to get martin luther
king to kill himself okay uh so there's
and then may have may or may not have
played a role in that as well may or may
not have played a role in the
assassination of malcolm x as well so
the fbi historically is is always been
an instant is it been an arm of of uh
white supremacist terror okay all right
okay infiltration of of black
organizations uh you know labor uh
pro-labor organizations they played a
role in the red scare propaganda that's
impossible but even in contemporary yeah
i was let's talk about contemporary
because that that's all i mean it's all
relevant right but we're talking about
stuff from like the 50s and [ __ ] in
contemporary uh history uh even under
the obama administration is certainly
under the george w bush administration
and even under trump the fbi played a
fundamental role in oppressing and and
uh engaging in uh mass surveillance of
muslims
uh in the united states that makes sense
like in the wake of 9 11. yeah one of
their most common practices was to go
and find
um like autistic or or like you know
mentally
uh disabled muslim teenagers on the
internet and then
give them and then coerce them basically
into doing a terror plot
and then
foil that terror plot so they could be
like look terror is all around us muslim
terror is really terrifying uh and we
did a great job stopping it and of
course
a similar thing that they did with the
gresham whitmer kidnapping situation i
don't know if you remember that it was
kind of identical to that but instead
but this time it was white people so
like obviously uh you know
that was more publicized but when it's a
muslim teenager that's like autistic
like no one gives a [ __ ]
but uh the fbi did a lot of that like
the majority i think of the terror plots
they foiled were uh terror plots that
they themselves had facilitated uh
supplied logistics for
um
oh here's a here's an article the
unlikely jihadi that i pressured a
lonely young man into a bomb plot he
tried to back out
now he's serving life in prison yeah
that sounds fair that sounds like a good
story yeah that's so that's a pretty
common practice for the fbi
um it sounds like there's some really
god-awful like divisions yeah i think
what happens and stuff like that is in
the wake of 9 11 they have this
directive from like the president top
down that it's like we need to
investigate terrorism and show the
american public that we're catching foil
and terrorism and then they end up like
with these creatures
so they're like we gotta make the
terrorism ourselves and then catch it
so that that is bad yeah that's bad yeah
so there are let's defund them
so i'm on board uh you know bring it
down to its bare bones and only
do this like only sex trafficking
sex crimes homicides
financial crimes financial crimes uh
political crimes
political crimes absolutely that's a lot
just arrest like arrest politicians
every every every couple of weeks just
like throw a politician in jail like i
think that would be cool yeah that would
really beef up their numbers i think
that that would really improve their
approval rating amongst like the
american public is like nobody like
congress approval rating is 17 just
arrest some of these mothers oh my god
dude you know what i mean wait this is a
really interesting comment from me
minnie lindsay she says hi
i'm a larry nassar survivor he was the
the olympic gymnast coach another great
example of the uh fbi uh that's what
she's negligence the fbi knew larry was
abusing little girls for nine months and
let larry see 70 new patients while
taking bribes from the usag we are
currently suing them for a billion
dollars wow dude yeah if i would be
[ __ ] f i am that's [ __ ] up yeah
that's horrible
so there's plenty there's plenty that
they don't do and they should do and
then there's plenty that where they do a
lot where they shouldn't it's just cops
they're federal cops so of course just
like the police force like
i uh as much as i criticize the police
force i understand the necessity for
some like
organization some unit that maintains
the presence of law and order there's a
necessity for you know people to solve
crimes you know i mean like detectives
and whatnot and so i understand that but
they don't really do that and that's
kind of what we're angry at with respect
to
all my criticisms of the police and the
fbi is just the you know police on
steroids kind of okay
so basically what we've done is that the
the conservatives now have gone all full
circle and become
radical leftists defunding the police so
that's we that's actually terrific
we're on board with that they've always
had a like a anti-atf streak like old
school
um the old school libertarians old
school conservatives like used to hate
kind of hate the fbi as well like
reason.com libertarians you know
um so i'm glad that they're going back
to their roots
well let's start from the beginning so
yeah a couple of days ago uh fbi agents
raided trump's house at mar-a-lago and
took
uh
took a few
baskets of documents they also broke
into a safe
did not break into a safe they had a
warrant
that specifically
uh had to have dictated that the safe
was uh accessible yeah but they they
access to safe which is not easy to get
a warrant for no it is not
it's a it's a
it's a different
search warrant that you need to get like
for example when you do
when you execute a search warrant
normally
and you go into a house and there's a
safe
uh oftentimes they'll hold up the
they'll hold up the the raid they'll
stop it
and wait for a secondary warrant to come
in specifically for that save
um part of the reason why i mean this
was a beefy warrant right right and the
reason why that's important is because
you can't get a beefy warrant like this
unless you have someone on the inside
that is turned that has turned states
witness and that's the speculation is
that someone um
with
access to this level of knowledge within
the trump circle
um
offered this this information that like
uh these classified documents were being
held inside a trump safe otherwise they
would not have been able to get that
warrant it's hard to imagine like this
person who knocked on him must be
i mean imagine how close you have to be
to know what's in his safe that what
classified documents he stole i mean
that's got to be fairly close proximity
but regardless what really happened at
now that we know a few days have passed
is that when he was president when he
was leaving the white house he basically
just grabbed
a [ __ ] load of classified documents and
stole them he at one point returned them
at the request of the national archive
and the fbi but he didn't return all of
them he kept some
and it's speculated the ones he did keep
because the fbi obviously went to a
great length to get them back were
fairly sensitive important documents
that he stole you could imagine he stole
him for a reason right
yeah so the fear and i think that this
is a pretty reasonable uh
fear to have if you are the fbi or if
you are like uh you know working inside
one of these federal agencies given
trump's track record of like uh
operating out of mar-a-lago and what
that presents as a matter of like uh a
security concern
as a matter of national security because
mar-a-lago is a country club they are
not vetting every single person that is
within proximity of donald trump and
donald trump literally throughout his
presidency got into trouble for
conducting business presidential
business in mar-a-lago around foreign
nationals
um so that was uh that was a serious uh
problem for them there was even
incidents of like
random people or there was like a
chinese spy you remember that who got
into mar-a-lago and got two yeah
well also maria bettina famously uh a
russian spy marie betuna famously went
all the way up as well so they didn't
even have to use mar-a-lago just use the
regular lobbying arm of the nra but
um
so my point was that uh it's
understandable that they would be
worried that this kind of classified
material is still in the possession of
the former president
normally as a as a matter of courtesy
presidents basically hand off
uh declassification to the next
president that comes in
or sorry uh the
new president basically says you can
still have uh like some level of of uh
you can still stay in some level of like
in the know as a former president which
biden uh unceremoniously did not offer
to donald trump citing uh national
security concerns so that's another
reason why like trump cannot have
possession of these classified documents
um
but like i said i i hope that there is
more to it than just like mismanaged
files
right unfortunately i think that's it i
don't think anything else is going to
come with this well then then
republicans are going to make mincemeat
out of this they're going to what are
they going to do because they got to
make up their mind is this like a civil
war grab or
is this just like he has these documents
ever since watergate
we passed a law saying that every
presidential document has to be saved
and filed with the national archive by
law okay
and so trump
while he was in the white house was
tearing up documents he was even
flushing documents like what the [ __ ]
and now he's stealing documents they
begged him to return it
and after exhausting all civil options
trump that was basically the only way
left to get the documents is to go to
[ __ ] mar-a-lago and take them from
what i can tell
i think that's it dude
um i hope that there is a more to it
than that and it like somehow links back
to january 6 because there's a secondary
investigation
uh on uh donald trump's involvement that
the january 6 committee is looking at
um they also seized the phone of
a
of a
congressperson from uh pennsylvania
including five additional people from
the state legislature i believe uh uh in
in pennsylvania
with direct links to january 6 and they
were communicating with donald trump and
the the uh
the the congress person's phone that was
seized the pennsylvania republican
representative scott perry um he was
talking with the trump white house uh
in the months leading up to january 6
about the insurrection and he's like a
freedom caucus guy he's like a tea party
guy so you know big
big libertarian hours they didn't take
computers or phones or anything from
trump did they i don't think so no they
only took his phone one day after the
raid so i'm hoping that like there is i
did take trump's phone
no they took his phone that's what i'm
saying they didn't take any electronics
from trump no they did not they did not
and trump of course uh pled the fifth in
a testimony yesterday which is great
yeah as he once famously said multiple
pull up uh he says
who would take the fifth other than a
criminal um i mean he was right
right yeah
but he's morally consistent on that one
he's right on the nose with this one
here check this out trump takes it god
he looks like [ __ ] here bro who what the
[ __ ] is that
looks like a cadaver like a wreath
he's not looking his best self that's
like an open casket funeral showing
[ __ ] me yeah it sucks look how beautiful
he was in 2016. yeah he was well he
doesn't have his makeup on so yeah he'll
come back again stronger than ever
before
yeah check check check this out guys you
see the mob takes it
if you're innocent why are you taking
the fifth amendment former president
trump indeed fled the fifth he refused
to answer questions from the ag and
indeed invoked his fifth amendment
rights taking the fifth
i think it's disgraceful
what a [ __ ] loser actually you know
what he's not the loser the people that
like him are losers i mean you you're
like
such a sucker dude this man's a con
artist like how much more clear does it
need to be i did a whole like someone
found a bunch of uh hogs on tick tock
talking about like how
you know they're terrified of like the
fbi coming after them now and they're
terrified of the 87 000 new irs agents
yeah and they think like these iris
agents are gonna come in with guns and
like you know kill them or something
because they're conservative which is
awesome i love that they like live in a
state of panic all the time
um
but uh you know the the attitude from
the most radicalized trump supporters is
that like this is civil war folks it's
like right it's happening um one of my
favorite takes on it was again from like
uh on on the donald there was like some
[ __ ] random guy
who was talking about how like get your
guns ready civil war is coming you know
i'm ready for this i can't wait for this
or whatever and then he self-doxed and
said i'm currently under trial i'm under
uh you know my trial date for january 6
is coming up in a month and it's like
bro why did you willingly hand over that
information to like random people on the
internet on a public [ __ ] forum i'm
ready for war right when i get out of
prison for insurrection and two yeah
like what like it's wild he's like
he just wants to do more of the thing
that he's currently about to go to jail
for he says when you let me out i will
do the same thing i gotta wrestle for
yeah it's like it's like the alex jones
trial you know what i mean like is the
alex roshan like defaming the judge on a
defamation trial it's so [ __ ] good
service case is a demon a pedophile
but this is important
a lot of people say
hassan why are they doing this like why
are they so stupid and it's not just
idiocy that guides them to be this way i
think the secondary
uh the the secondary reasoning or maybe
the primary reasoning other than how
stupid they are because of course
they're stupid is the entitlement
conservatives love to act like the
police force and the fbi and these
institutions are totally
colorblind and actually uh do not uh do
not oppress the marginalized communities
right
until
until
they are treated
like someone who is not above the law in
which case they immediately give the
game away that's why they're freaking
out right it's the greatest crime ever
yes
perpetrated yeah this is the very same
people that were defending the police on
a no-knock warrant
on uh briana taylor's house yeah the
very same people turned around and said
like this is worse than anything
anyone's ever done this is a civil war
this is civil war before they even knew
why the fbi did it which is so great
this is a civil war this is unacceptable
this is so cruel and so unusual and so
humiliating it's like what do you mean
you don't even know what happened why it
happened but speaking of brianna taylor
the development in that has been
absolutely chilling dude
like it's even worse so they they
arrested the cops finally
and yeah the details that came out was
that like they straight up fabricated
the warrant
because there was some conspiracy to try
to get black people to move out of this
apartment building because there was
like a new developer that wanted to move
in i mean it's so
[ __ ] up
yeah i mean it's uh it's it's
it's not any different than anything
i've ever advocated for especially
considering the role that police play as
an arm of capital they are still
very much protecting and serving the
interests of capital
well so anyway
let's get back on the timeline so
he gets rated it's big news and then he
kind of actually breaks the news with
this truth social post
statement by donald trump
45th president of the united states i
love it these are dark times for our
nation our beautiful home our logo in
palm beach florida is currently under
siege raided and occupied by a large
group of fbi agents nothing like this
has ever happened to a president united
states before that's true
but again they what they what they draw
from that
is not that donald trump is so corrupt
that this has now happened to anyone
else is that the f the whole
institution of the fbi is so corrupt
it's interesting how they do that
after working and cooperating with the
relevant government agencies this
unannounced raid on my home was not
necessarily appropriate
it is prosecuted prosecutorial
uh misconduct the weaponization of the
justice system and an attack by radical
left democrats who desperately don't
want me to run for president 2024
especially based on recent polls who
will likewise do anything to stop
republican and conservatives in the
upcoming midterm election such an
assault could only take place in broken
third world countries yeah no this would
never happen
i see that echoed a lot and i'm like
isn't it good that a democracy holds its
leaders to account like
in a third world
this would never happen because yeah no
he's basically saying that the the
weaponization of the uh federal agencies
against the prior political opponent
is third world country [ __ ] which i mean
as an american president he should know
that it's something that the american
government oftentimes plays a role in in
like you know latin american countries
and whatnot
all around the third world in developing
nations as a matter of fact but you're
right this is uh no matter how nerdy it
is even if it's like mismanagement of
classified information would still be uh
technically some level of genuine
accountability
uh and it's like the the bare minimum
yeah i just hate that it's uh i wish
that it was i mean all former presidents
are crooks and and awful for the most
part
so it is kind of sad that this
is how we we finally like bring about
some level of accountability to a former
president you know what i mean which is
why i'm still holding out hope that the
fbi was not so
so silly to just simply conduct this
raid for
um for for documents some documents that
were mismanaged i'm holding out hope but
at this point every single inquiry into
him has been utter nothing burger slash
disappointment and i'm sure this will be
no different
anyways because that does have a
galvanizing factor like
that does that does end up uh you know
bringing more support within it the fbi
has only ever since hillar the hillary
clinton benghazi email investigation era
has only ever aided conservatives 100
you are correct
this is another thing yeah you're
absolutely correct on that a lot of
people say like russia russia russia
except like
james comey's
second investigation 11 days out of the
election
which and which led to nothing by the
way just a repeat of the prior
investigation that unironically had a
much larger impact on the 2016 election
yeah than anything else probably changed
the i mean there's a good chance to
change that yeah because that was won by
margins that was won by margins and i do
think that like
obviously outside of like hillary
clinton's campaign and it's like
incompetence and
and the dnc's incompetence and disdain
for its uh you know for its voter base
but the electoral ecology
outside of all those factors jim comey
100 played a larger role than russia did
i mean the optics of the fbi opening
announcing publicly they're opening an
investigation into a candidate 11 days
out i mean that's like
that's basically like a plan i mean
that's just like
planned propaganda it's so it's so
unusual to do that too they even have a
policy not to the 90-day influence
elections like that 90 days out from a
trial so why the [ __ ] did is comey an
acid i mean it's just so weird and then
trump turned on him of course too and
fired him
but why would he do that why how could
he be so incompetent or i don't know
it's just hard to imagine but the fbi
has only ever aided them and this is and
in my opinion
this is what's going to happen as a
result of this as well
because i again i don't think anything
is going to come out of it and it's just
going to turn into this insane
fundraising which you already see
happening immediately
yeah it does make me happy to see them
cry though it is it's great it makes me
so happy so for that reason like i don't
even give a [ __ ] if this is like uh you
know
uh allowing donald trump to like whip up
support i don't care at all at a time
when he was like kind of falling off ron
desantis was like on the rise you know
what i mean all i want to see is trump
versus desantis i'm living for that i
don't think that'll happen what i don't
think that'll happen they're two they're
too like
what they're too
uh uh
desantis is definitely vying for
for the nominee yeah i know but i think
ron desantis right now well first of all
rhonda sans is like literally a carbon
copy of trump or tries to yeah but he's
not
he's more polished he's more you know
he's left yes which is why i think the
republican establishment probably like
him more because he thinks
you think trump doesn't have a chance at
the nominee no i think trump will be the
nominee unless you like there's gonna be
a there's gotta be a clash and trump is
gonna like
eviscerate uh desantis
i don't know man i see
i think like they'll probably i think
there's more like
internal uh collusion within the
republican ranks
especially now that they have completely
become the trump party it's probably
true but because like remember 2016 like
the primaries in that on that front were
were a joke i mean trump just ripped
through all of them yeah like probably
destroyed their their political careers
to a degree where they all have to
concede
and and you know despite trump saying
like ted cruz your wife is ugly ted cruz
is like [ __ ] on the phones
you know smiling and dialing for donald
trump i saw a comment a comic of trump
and ted cruz meeting
and trump's like hey ted how's your ugly
wife something
great mr president
we like to troll
yeah we'll see i don't know but trump is
so off the hinges that
you never know but you know
as you can
by my estimate it ends up not really
being a big deal and the moment it
happens right there's a complete and
utter conservative meltdown it's civil
war it's it's civil war they're ready
they have their arms they're ready to go
uh so i've got rubicon has been crossed
i've got first of all some of my
favorite
uh
uh triggered uh snowflake tweets
tim poole of course uh
what is the rubicon
um reference to ancient rome
rubicon was a river
uh that julius caesar crossed
or was it river or is that the name of
the uh the shallow river yeah yeah it is
the river right
uh but it just means like it's it's a
turning point essentially yeah crowd i
do crowder i can't wait he goes you'll
remember this day he starts crying
you'll remember this day for the rest of
your life
this is the day everything changes
anyway marjorie was ready to defund the
fbi
which um they're such babies like this
is not it's not like they they didn't
even kill donald trump's dogs or
anything you know what i mean like
that's like bare minimum of police [ __ ]
well they're talking like they didn't
flashbang like baron you know what i
mean they didn't none of that happened
right and these [ __ ] are acting
like it's the worst thing that has ever
happened in the history of america
you're right if you
if you think that they went in and
assassinated trump or something that's
basically the reaction you would expect
from that
um the rubicon has been crossed marjorie
taylor gross uh uh titan gross with the
upside down flag shout out
queen
but like i said this is an admission
it's like these agencies they're
basically saying these agents are
supposed to work for us right it's that
same level of entitlement that that
caused them to like live stream
themselves breaking into the [ __ ]
halls of congress it's that same level
of entitlement that caused them to say i
can't believe we're political prisoners
of the american federal government uh
for for what
smallest
the smallest enforcement yeah kevin
mccartney
mccarthy of course the uh
minority leader
he says attorney general garland
preserve your documents and clear your
calendar shut up [ __ ] like he didn't
already and these guys are all like big
bold badasses but ultimately all they
were saying on fox news was just go out
and vote go out and vote vote hard
[ __ ] and buy my mug and at least
stephen crowder was like trying to sell
his [ __ ] mug club and and being like
oh there's a civil war upon us and we
gotta we gotta ready our troops uh you
gotta buy my money of course find out
yeah you gotta purchase my t-shirt that
says fight like hell
yeah that's how you're gonna show
uh everyone how how angry you are by
buying my my indonesian t-shirts
so [ __ ] stupid bro uh kevin mccarthy
says i've seen enough
the department of justice has reached an
intolerable state of weaponized
political politicalization
when republicans take back the house we
will conduct immediate oversight of this
department follow the facts and leave no
stone unturned
attorney general garland preserve your
documents and clear your calendar
they're turning into libs it's awesome
like the slight bit of pushback
and and they turn into like liberals
like this is some [ __ ] chris murphy
would type
you know what i mean i i love that i
love that they're just saying stuff like
this
um and and basically urging everyone to
vote harder vote harder
and i don't know i don't know if that's
gonna i don't know if this is gonna cut
it i don't know if this is going to
actually get people to go out and vote
in the midterms because like how do you
how do you uh square that hole you know
well the thing is i don't know that it's
necessarily going to help trump though
because also it's not great optics that
the president got raided by the fbi too
and there's going to be a lot of people
like you know
i'm sick of this [ __ ] guy
there's always something going on
and the fbi wouldn't be raiding his
house if he didn't do some [ __ ] so
i don't think it's an automatic w for
him i mean it's definitely going to help
raise money but i don't know if he's
going to help get more votes
andrew yang
friend of the show i hate andrea he has
really lost his way man i can't say that
i support him
this whole forward party [ __ ] is just a
little bit more i was so right on andrew
yang being a total [ __ ] loser cuck
with no like
consistent and genuine interest in like
uh you know bettering the lives of
americans and i was so goddamn right on
tulsi gabbard everyone called yeah tulsi
tulsi ended up the worst i mean yeah
she's a [ __ ] demon i'm just saying
because like a russian asset bro
these two people popped off on the
internet and that's where we're at so
that's why people would come in and be
like you don't like tulsi what the [ __ ]
what do you love imperialism i was like
bro she's literally working with the cia
in africa like while you're typing this
out shut the [ __ ] up um you know and you
yang with his universal in basic income
i thought was great and i think it it
actually did have some positive
influences
but i don't know where the [ __ ] he's on
with this [ __ ] the moment that this
raid became public he goes i'm no trump
fam i want him as far away from the
white house as possible but the
fundamental part of his appeal has been
that it's him against a corrupt
government establishment this rage
strengthens that case for millions of
americans who will see this
as unjust persecution
the point makes no [ __ ] sense are you
saying that you can't ever
you can't ever prosecute a leader
because of the optics like what yeah no
i love the tape because like millions of
americans also think the election was
stolen and that like uh you know
everyone everyone in the democratic
party are running a pedophile ring so
it's really [ __ ] up if you guys like
investigate sex traffickers it's so like
it's actually so you're just gonna only
strengthen their idiocy okay you're
gonna you're gonna give them the support
and then the next part is even dumber
it's like what the he goes it seems like
this was an author authorized by a local
uh fbi officer trump appointed fbi
director without buying or notification
of higher levels of government but
literally no one believed that or make a
distinction what where do you where are
you getting that information bro no
there first of all it is a judge uh it
was a trump appointee judge and trump's
very own fbi director christopher wray
that oversaw this uh operation
of course gonna reach the highest levels
within the fbi i don't give a [ __ ] what
the fbi says i do believe that they
might have kept the government out of
the loop like they might have kept the
white house out of the loop but andrew's
making it sound like it was some rope
tiny rogue office and like uh yeah the
back waters of that that's a wild yeah
that's a wild take because like this is
a previous president
what are you talking yeah what the [ __ ]
you don't conduct a search on a prior
pres previous president's no home
without the highest levels of fbi being
involved in it uh so and he goes if they
raided his home just to find classified
documents he took from the white house
one legal expert noted who he will be
re-elected president in 2024 heads down
is that legal expert tucker carlson it
will be proven to be the greatest law
enforcement mistake in history i mean
okay andrew uh
i don't know what the [ __ ] you're doing
but stop it
we don't like it i mean he's doing he's
he's just farming clicks
that's all he's doing he's gonna do
anything there's no viable like there's
no way in hell andrew yang has like a
viable third party also his third party
ron is just basically more of the
democratic party
it's so weird centrist fence sitting
[ __ ] yeah we already have one of
those parties man and it's like
profoundly successful okay you know in
comparison to your [ __ ] it's just this
is like
bro stop it oh by the way in in response
to um andrew yang's incredible
insight here's the headline from the new
york times fake news new york times
subpoena preceded search warrant and
pushed to retrieve material from trump
the justice department had sought the
return of classified documents i believe
might be at mar-a-lago before it sent
fbi agents this took
a week uh agents this week yeah
entitlement like subpoena is subpoenas
are sent to people who are willing
participants
so wait they said once you become an
unwilling once you're no longer
willing to collaborate with the federal
government
then yeah they're going to [ __ ] knock
down your door
and and use the secret service to unlock
all the doors all these fake friends out
there you know trump is out there with
these big big beautiful
secret services what i heard is that
their their
the secret service didn't participate in
the
is that what you heard yeah i want to
believe that they did regardless i heard
that there there was some confusion
between them as you can imagine but that
they didn't participate
they didn't want to betray the big
beautiful president yeah
but uh so there you go i mean trump knew
this was coming that's the funny part
they were literally like dude you have
to remove these documents you have to
give us these documents back i can see
him not thinking that they would
actually conduct this raid though
because it does seem like he was a
little hysterical when he popped off
with that whole they broke even into my
even into my safe
that was so funny not the safe no
i mean it is a lot let's be honest by
the way a garland has a press conference
in 15 minutes so keep us updated on that
dan uh now five minutes yeah it's
supposed to start in uh do we know
what's the topic or anything
uh
it is unknown if he will address the fbi
execution warrant
um
i mean you could assume it's gonna be
about this but also right before we went
live there was a story an fbi office in
ohio uh was shot up or something or
somebody showed up oh yeah that's the
wonderful thing there's people out there
no no there are people out there which
is one of the funniest things you can do
people are doxing
uh merrick garland christopher wray and
they're like making threats to their
lives and that is the funniest thing you
can do he's like literally the head of
the department of justice yeah or or the
[ __ ] head of the fbi he's like i am
the biggest police
armed man tried to breach fbi cincinnati
building authorities say there is no
brandon no there is nothing funnier than
this
this is literally stephen crowder
because of this no straight up like fast
track perma prison you know what i mean
like it's it's awesome yeah no go ahead
go off kings like have fun with it i
guess yeah that's funny that is true
that is the probably the single worst
person in the country to try to [ __ ]
with you know it's kind of like you were
saying hassan
the old school republicans used to hate
the atf and everything yeah you know how
like you know bucket hats and stuff are
back 90s fashion
it's the full 90s back we got
republicans attacking fbi offices yeah
once the national republican party
starts making tort reform their main
plank i'm uh we're back there you go
it's juicy yeah alex jones thing they
may they very well may yeah i can't wait
to find out this guy who tried to shoot
up fbi
office is a fan of crowder and [ __ ] it's
going to be great well that's not going
to mean anything though obviously
because steven crowder
he's not calling for civil war he's just
simply stating it and then being like
but not violent of course not he goes i
think that this is going to be that
we're not none of us were everyone's
gonna remember where you were when this
happened it's an all-out civil war we
cannot allow this one inch further we're
not gone for violence we cannot allow
one more millimeter we're not for
violence though
not
i love it to be honest i i do it's great
you know let him let him have some fun
let him have some fun with it house
judiciary gop says if they can do it to
a former president imagine what they can
do to you uh yeah bro they can already
do whatever the [ __ ] they want yeah
that's and they have been and now it's
actually equitable so great
that's the that's the funniest part
about this sounds great
just like uh yeah dude imagine if you
were like also holding on to classified
documents that the government nicely
politely asked to retrieve what if i
stole classified documents they wouldn't
[ __ ] ask politely for like two years
yeah they'd [ __ ] helicopter into your
house yeah
uh so great i love that our leaders can
be held accountable what a great country
we live in where corruption doesn't
100 protect
ex-presidents well nearly yeah but like
i said i'm an equal opportunity guy on
this like if you want to [ __ ] throw
some democrats in the pile
that's great more more for me more fun
for me i'm on board
go get hunter
yeah they're all not talking about
hunter he's not hunter i love loner
hunter
it's so funny how hunters become the
specter of just like not hunter don't
touch hunter i will i will do a waco
style defensive hunter okay i will
barricade myself with a bunch of weapons
inside of hunter biden's compound we
have enough crack to last us a a very
long time in there do not come in
yeah you should party with hunter it'd
be fun i will defend hunter
with my life anthony
sabatini said it's time for us from
florida legislators to call an emergency
legislative session and amend our laws
regarding federal agencies sever all
ties with the with the uh department of
justice immediately i don't think that's
how that works idiot no i hope it does
any fbi agent conducting law enforcement
functions outside the purview of our
state should be arrested upon sight i
mean this man is basically
what you're saying is so [ __ ] insane
bro no i love it it's awesome please
please i have a i have a plan he says
any federal agent is on site yeah
no i'm on site i have a plan i
personally believe that like florida
should actually be uh
removed like florida should be allowed
to secede first of all they're gonna be
underwater anyway well you know the
panama canal they they said it was
impossible we can panama panama canal
the top of florida yeah
i think that we
my plan was that we take all the border
wall that we've already built and like
drop ship it directly on the border of
florida so there's like attack on titan
style like multiple walls outside of
florida that are impossible to breach
and then we often will go in with
helicopters and like take you know
people who aren't psychotic crypto
uh loving uh pedophiles out of florida
because that would be a human rights
abuse for them to live in florida yeah
and just you know
mass migration of all libertarians into
florida
i haven't been your own crypto parent
well this is what he's fantasizing of
essentially i mean your tweet bro i mean
in seriousness to actually suggest this
as a representative is like dude
come on
a crowder of course who in my opinion is
the main source of any violence that
happens probably tomorrow is war sleep
well
all i'm saying is there's a big jobs
program uh taking everybody out of
florida that doesn't want to be there
anymore
you know what i mean you spread them out
to all the red states as well all of a
sudden boom all those red states uh have
a blossoming new economy smart
to the attorney general fbi director
release the warrant now the american
people deserve to see it now ted cruz is
such a vile [ __ ] and as even cuomo
acknowledged it must be more than a
search oh now you now you're quoting
cuomo yeah you know that's really fun
said you know what's really funny about
this is uh
you know you know who else could
actually release the warrant
donald trump
donald trump could have released the war
got it
but he got it
he got not only subpoena but he has the
warrant that's awesome that's so why
doesn't he [ __ ] release it ted that's
so true huh
yeah cause this has to be antagonistic
towards the attorney general and the fbi
director because they want to like
politicize it which i do think there is
like a a political undertone to it
obviously you can't go after a former
president without it being like at least
some level political so i'll give it
i'll give that to him right i i'll admit
that i'm willing to admit that
yeah the best part about this is
basically it's almost
it's extremely likely that someone very
close to them tipped off the fbi and
that's how they were able to know
exactly where it is that's how they got
into the safe so that's
that's an interesting aspect
another interesting aspect the extra
irony is that trump approved the law
during the
email scandal with hillary
yeah that increased the punishment for
mishandling classified information
because of the law that he championed
to pres you know in response to hillary
he could face five years in prison if
he's found guilty under the national
security bill which he signed as
president so good it's so [ __ ] good
it upgraded the series trump's own
judges his own fbi director
hitting him with the max penalty that he
himself pushed for that is
oh so good
i don't like it well i do uh it upgraded
the seriousness of wrongly moving
classified materials does that include
putting it all in like a [ __ ]
like when you get what does you call
that kind of cardboard box when you get
like fired you put all your [ __ ] in it
and do like the walk of shame yeah
so a banker box a banker box
yeah does it says wrongly moving
classified material does that include
stuffing them into a banker box and
running from the white house
turning it from a misdemeanor into a
felony and increasing the maximum
punishment from one year to five years
passed in the wake of trump's relentless
attacks during the 2006 presidential
campaign on hillary clinton
for
mismanda
mishandling classified information gotta
love that
i mean these guys were doing the exact
same thing that they were criticizing
hillary clinton for immediately like the
transition team was using private
servers mike pence was using private
servers donald trump was using private
servers
i mean
he had private citizens without proper
security clearance in the highest levels
of government uh for the longest time
like jared kushner and you know ivanka
so
the idea that like you know this is
exclusive to hillary clinton is silly
but what is exclusive to the republican
party is of course the comically sized
hats yeah so his fans have come out to
mar-a-lago to pro i love this including
this queen
who
has stepped up the maga hat game 100 um
to and i i don't know can we buy one of
those dan can we acquire some of those
i'm a little jealous oh look because
that is [ __ ] fire it's so [ __ ]
funny to like try to make a serious
point while you put on the most
comically sized hat you could find she's
completely serious in this yeah no
that's an ounce that juxtaposition is is
incredible so here hard hitting from is
that the nacho hat you remember that
simpsons yeah it is it
anyway here it is uh
administration the democrats are
weaponizing the fbi and it has to stop
the fbi is not here to weaponize against
another president it never has happened
before
they should go ma'am are you aware
there's a giant uh
hat on your head
yeah people thinks that are clearly a
violation meaning the hunter laptop
which they don't even have to
investigate
the laptop is right there all the
evidence is there hillary all of that is
not investigated president trump is
investigated because he said that he's
running
and he will win again
oh
such an unserious person dude all facts
that's so awesome and then like
like
these are the same uh people especially
the chronically online conservatives who
are like look how [ __ ] look how the
libtards are so silly they're always
like crying and they look so lame and
then like that's the
that's the best person you could find to
go to you know stop the the mar-a-lago
raid from happening so true it's so true
here's laura ingraham one of the top fox
people um
with a very measured and calm response
uh deep state's revenge
twenty bucks oh here we found the hat
hold on hold on laura hold on to that
thought giant foam make america great
again hat we need you want one of those
for some we're gonna buy it for everyone
look if i use let's go brandon 10 i get
brandon
let's go brandon yeah use that code who
wants a who wants a
who wants one of these i don't want i
gotta want one
absolutely not no okay i'm good before
you speak too soon
no i want that one oh i want that one
that's definitely one i do want oh my
god he's next to mike pence
yeah
i don't want that one too man is that
the one mega black guy that they always
travel no that's not michael the black
there's a few more his name's the black
yeah
his last name is the black no that's
what he goes by though he calls himself
michael the black man or michael the
black oh he tokenizes himself is that an
ar foam finger okay i'm serious though
damn paul i want to get i want to buy
some of that loot bring it back okay i
want to shop right now i want the cowboy
hat all right let's see if i can find
one secondhand on ebay so we don't give
these people money
but if not i don't want someone just
have to do it yeah look they made a good
product let them get paid
it's probably some people in china
anyway you know yeah that's true
what is happening to me i don't know
what's happening just i want to see that
giant hats
we're having technical issues there now
that
it's actually a normal sized hat that's
a vibe though yeah that's a normal sized
hat on my i feel like my voice should be
different i feel like i should talk like
this yeah
um
just get a couple cowboy hats dan get a
couple of yeah i'll get a variety we got
a variety pack yeah get the variety pack
thank you also i don't understand why oh
i see why the website it's political
targets and you can buy
you can pee on joe brandon's face
or wipe your ass with his face an eight
dollar roll
of sandpaper yeah that seems
excellent and somehow still better than
nfts
that's still more valuable still more
utility more practical applications
maybe yeah you could wipe your ass with
it all right let's see what laura
ingraham has to say
of us that will be destroyed if we fight
them if we question the repeated
failures of the pentagon leadership if
we make serious i'm talking about
serious moves to disrupt the status quo
here in washington you know the status
quo that protects the powerful as long
as they play the game
this is the deep state's revenge
they're trying to show all of us bro the
insistence that trump isn't like a deep
deep state
or
established a status quo i mean it's all
it's like it's like like q and stuff
right i mean this is the basis of q and
on is that trump is like secretly still
fighting against the deep state and
that's why like you know there's bad
actors within the fbi and cia that are
like working against them
this certainly solidifies that in their
minds but i mean those people
are already insane like they are
deranged human beings so it doesn't
[ __ ] matter whether donald trump was
arrested by the fbi or not those people
were still deranged they're still going
to continue to be deranged
this clip of tin pool i just think he's
such a [ __ ] so it's just a little short
clip that's fun dude thinks he's in the
pirates of the caribbean by the way i
don't know what's going on back there i
i mean the katana is vibes
yo katanas are sick dude especially when
they're on the wall like that
another journalist they have confirmed
it
seems to be completely legit the hill is
reporting definitively that donald
trump's home has been raided by the fbi
it's unclear exactly why but boy do we
have to talk about this one because this
is uh it's one of those moments when you
question how long until dark days you
get really really dark you know
i just thought that was really poetic
dark days get really really dark yeah
it's kind of a beautiful
as opposed to dark days that are bright
right which would really be
you just don't understand like he said
really really dark yeah so the dark the
days are already dark but soon they'll
be really big yeah because brandon
brandon is killing everybody so really
really dark isn't
total darkness there's still space for
more it can get darker yeah it can get
darker darker yet
i don't want to say too much but there
are times in history when we talk about
when people realized things were getting
too dangerous in their own country i
think the former president having his
home raided by the fbi when he's already
passively announced he's going to be
running for president basically
passively announced you know it's funny
i agree it's bad
it's because our president is so [ __ ]
corrupt the fbi had to go into it how do
you interpret it the other way it's
incredible
well you do it because you know
you want to [ __ ] whip people up into
a frenzy
and and participate in a civil war that
you will not be engaging in and it's not
even going to be a civil war it's going
to be random dumbass lone wolf
stochastic terrorists like the guy in
cincinnati
that will
you know take matters in their own hands
after listening to too much tim poole
and then they'll get [ __ ] owned so
good luck good luck with that
so on to my favorite person who milked
this
really grifted and milked this the
hardest of course steven crowder
who is such a tough guy he won't even
[ __ ] debate sam cedar literally runs
and pees his [ __ ] pants when he sees
sam cedar a
middle-aged jewish man
over zoom no less this man is a coward
a child
and uh everything in between here he is
uh the title is fbi raise donald trump
this means war exclamation exclamation
exclamation capital war
i love this not violence though i love
this uh especially because like i don't
even think he's violent i don't
because he's like you'll see here i
don't want to spoil it here we go
we have a bunch of time stamps this is a
long episode but we we picked our
favorite moments to experience it with
you this is one of those
days
that you were going to remember you
started for the rest of your life this
is one of those days that you were going
one of those days when you don't want to
wake up everything is
everybody sucks bro my man my man is
acting like 9 11 just half yeah he's
acting like they assassinated donald
trump yeah
literally just went took some documents
911 mar-a-lago okay
you're laughing i know i should the fbi
retrieved documents that they politely
asked donald trump to give back yeah by
going into mar-a-lago while he wasn't
there and you're [ __ ] laughing ethan
i know i shouldn't be what the [ __ ] i'll
remember this day for the rest of my
life
telling your children about your
grandchildren about this is
a line that has been crossed
i almost cried it's been wrong
and let me just tell you this it can't
be unwrong he's i love that he's crying
yeah that's awesome what a [ __ ]
he's such he's such a [ __ ] what a soy
boy
hey what's in those holsters little
[ __ ] uh
little bottles of soy
little water pistols yeah no he's just
like a nip he's you know what he drinks
out of a bottle with soy in it with a
nipple
i mean he's
listen you you mad you're failing to
recognize ethan
and this is a rookie mistake for you
this is not a one mug kind of day this
is a two mug kind of day look at that
yeah he doesn't have one mug he has two
mugs
you got two mugs out there little boy
serious business
are you crying
why don't we get you your juice box and
a little nap time
you're obviously tired
yeah yeah
you're
you're over stimulated let's get you in
a dark room
come on sweetheart
all right let's continue
just before we move on today we're going
to get into what we know there's a lot
of misinformation out there
and i and i will spread it now largely
from the left in mainstream media
we'll get into what
so awesome
the fbi is doing what the fbi is not
doing but before any of that
last night i thought about uh you know
doing a video on instagram something
while this was happening or going to a
live stream in that moment because we've
done that in the past
i was conflicted
and let me explain to you what i mean um
you're mad
i'm mad
you're pissed
rightfully so
good sound bite uh potential there's act
that is good but you don't want to make
decisions at that point
you want to make decisions that are
measured and appropriate
right like declaring war civil war
yeah
he's like i broke i broke through so
much drywall last night
you don't understand okay
you don't get it not a drywall left in
sight that was on hold
and you don't want to interrupt your
enemy while they're making a mistake so
that's what i was thinking about
yeah like the [ __ ] fbi is watching
louder with crowd or bro stop
well he's yeah i mean
he's just really emotionally then let
him go yeah an emotional rant i'm sorry
i'll let him 911 just happened you're
laughing i know i know it's worse than
911. yeah where were you when trump it's
too late raided by
mar-a-lago
strategy what does this mean obviously
this is going to have some backlash uh
with the midterms
how should we couch our words i always
try and be pretty prudent with issues
like this yeah i'm sure and then i found
myself at the crossroads
uh if you have children by the way they
shouldn't be watching the show today
yeah kids don't watch yeah on on the day
when i'm like recreating the george
floyd execution
that's kid-friendly
or on any number of days where i'm doing
like uh like a chris tucker
impersonation while talking about obama
um right you know all of the other days
is
children
wait i'm sorry i'm sorry to pause it but
i just kind of noticed something
crossroads of i don't care and [ __ ] you
watch this when he just scratches cam
can you grab this
how did you nail that yeah grab the
scratching and just loop cam is uh cam
had to go oh [ __ ] can you do that can
someone else do that for me that is an
insane find dude look at this it's so
funny i noticed that last night too
you're talking about the scratching he
just sits there in silence and scratches
i just want to loop that
okay let's see what i can do yeah listen
he's he's a he's
neurodivergent at a liner
he's stimming what's wrong with you yeah
are you gonna how are you gonna call
that out right now this is quite ableist
of you yeah yeah
i know shame on me wrong
so tyrannical there needs to be a hill
that you're willing to die on
self-soothing yeah
this is it now i don't mean literally i
guess you do
i'm not calling you to violence unlike
what's being implied on twitter eric
swabble with a fight like hell i do love
banging chinese
i do love like minecraft twitter stephen
crowder you know what i mean
he's like
he's just if he was like that but still
was doing the same commentary anyway
that's like a total bayonet on your
muskets we are going to hand-to-hand
combat in minecraft
no he's uh no no that's not what i'm
saying but it doesn't matter he's he is
going to do that though yeah he already
did he says i'm not calling for violence
anyway
and then the you know what they call the
opening chapter a call to action
yeah what's the action
you'll see
in a second
me spies
um
you're mad now
we don't need to make our decisions
right now we do need to wait for some
information to come out but the world
needs to see that half of this country
is pissed i'm not saying make executive
decisions while you're pissed but we all
need to hit the purge button
and the world needs to see you hit the
purge button and we get to hit the purge
button with you so
i reserve the right to change my mind on
some things that i say today i reserve
the right with new information to maybe
change tact
but
today is a day that we all have the
right to be pissed off to yell to scream
bro this is some this is just great
that's the greatest this is some [ __ ]
[ __ ] like he's doing like uh
he's doing like a the the exact same
thing that he made fun of with like
democrats taking a day off when donald
trump became president you know what i
mean like everything that they made fun
of they are doing right now he's like
listen it's okay we need to do we need
to do mental health right now
they're doing a bodies and spaces the
fbi uh absolutely showed white male
aggression okay and that's fine a lot of
you are a lot of you uh have ptsd from
such things so we're just gonna we're
just gonna take a mental day we're gonna
take a me day today yeah you know and
you can scream into your pillow okay try
punching your pillow at home same [ __ ]
that they made fun of you're absolutely
right the thing is
with
being upset about donald trump winning
the presidency is an understandable uh
uh frustration right
it's not like anything bad happened
nothing happened retrieved files that
donald trump was not supposed to have
that's my favorite part is that all
these guys rushed out to make these
incredible like civil wars coming
comments they didn't even know what the
[ __ ] happened and now that we know it
was really a nothing burger here he is
this is my favorite part
he's choking back tears this is the most
important day of his life basically
right in all of our lives so important
in fact
you need to become a member to hear his
true thoughts that's the best part that
is the best part he's like what do you
do what can you do this man subscribe to
pay me a baby watch this is the grift is
just
a little bit with fire today we're also
going to get into i was really spending
all night and i didn't sleep much
thinking about what is it that i can do
what is it that we can do here or we can
offer you
quantifiable steps
that you can take
and some of those are going to have to
be addressed on mug club not on youtube
not because it's a call for violence
it's a call for
a physical civil war but because i want
to milk this as much as i can by
paywalling my commentary for all of you
dumb idiots who are stupid enough to go
yeah that's right there's a perfect
opportunity i need to get that mug yeah
it sounds like it'd be totally fine to
put on youtube uh excluding what you
just said
but because i don't know the rule book
and i know that they're on high alert
over there at youtube
that's awesome bro
but anyway if you want to get my full
thoughts on this uh segment you do need
to become a member
uh we'll be posting a members-only
version of me reacting to crowder
and the reason we'll do
the reason we're doing that is just
because
um
i want not a call for violence i want to
make money yeah we just want to make
more money but just to be clear it the
standard membership will not actually
get you access to this video is that
right yeah we're going to set it on the
tier three the uh 35 a month uh price
point yeah right it's twenty dollars
university baby bold water for everybody
sparkling waters for all
not you though because you spent all
your money on this instead
because that's what hustlers do
i mean the the hutzpah to to do it'd be
like yo what we need to do is put
content behind a pay wall uh yeah i mean
he's undermining his own message like
who the [ __ ] he's not buying i mean come
on
how dumb are you guys yeah no he's
undermining the overarching point that
he was trying to make about the severity
of the situation
okay that like uh it's a severe
situation the call to action for all
patriots
of course it's going to be behind a
paywall because i don't want to get in
trouble with you there's another point
in that video where he literally says
something along the lines of like
you know just buy my t-shirt to show
support to just show everybody like you
know cut out all the liberals from your
lives it's he tweeted this dude this guy
is such a yeah it's time to fight with
every square inch you guys how are you
not seeing this by the way that's the
most soy photo you could post like how
is this guy any different than like
every funko pop collector that he makes
fun of
this
shirt like dude come on this man tweeted
in the most important day of his life
it's time to fight for every square inch
use code fight
for fifteen percent off what did he what
what kind of uh interaction he got on
that
1441 line not a lot not a lot that one's
actually
that's a photoshop that's not real
here oh yeah we have the real one yeah
we have
the original right here it says micro
penis
you gotta fight for every square inch
how is he gonna fight like hell when his
heart gave out like
walking up the stairs yeah that's
another thing you got a heart issue bro
yeah stay home brother stay home you
know puffing cigars okay
by the way um
funny comments on underneath so by war
you mean shelling selling a shirt yeah
words tomorrow sleep well
that's so [ __ ] good man yeah
the grift couldn't be more uh blatant at
this point but there is no there is no
mechanism for pushback anyway
republicans get everything they want for
the most part regardless because
conservatives actually get what they
want because the republican party will
fight for them
so they're used to that already
light pushback from federal government
or anything like that is gonna cause
them to get mad but because there is no
like genuine mechanism to fight back or
hold the government accountable then all
you're gonna do is what like the only
thing we know how to do and we do that
best is consume right to buy more burgle
to buy burgle all day every day so
you're just buying steve crowder burgle
and and that's the only way you can show
your support
that's it
or yeah yeah it's great i mean it works
great for him this is this is when it
gets really off the rails i love this
he's um
he's gone like we said full circle come
he's a radical uh lib now check it out
any republican who does not actively
right now within the next what time is
it
10 18 eastern
by noon today
i love that he thinks that people
actually [ __ ] care about this
setting a deadline he's such a dumbass
what kind of power does he think he
holds over the republican party he
really is delusional no he thinks he's
he thinks he's fox news right now and
he's not you know what i mean it's just
not gonna happen it's just so delusional
bro looking
right now in office or running for
office who does not actively champion
the defunding the dismantling
of our intelligence agencies let's go i
will not go
i think it's just
i mean
it is based but i i love that it's all
intelligent agencies it's not even the
fbi no i'm so on board with that i mean
[ __ ] department of homeland security
abolish it that's new that's a new one
that's like that's not that old that's a
post 911 that is a post 911 agency right
take it out
abolish it destroy it okay sell it for
[ __ ] scrap metal here is a crowder uh
dreaming of abolishing all um
law enforcement agencies yeah he's
getting
he's getting thinking about it you need
a little you getting a little rash
a little diaper rash there
dan if you put like uh i love that
because it's like i don't know why it's
just such a like a childlike way of of
scratching your beard
he's self-soothing he is i mean i do it
all the time i bite my nails i put my
hair i skin pick so i get it yeah yeah
yeah we all got our things
[Music]
no it's a special you know it's it's a
lot of stress for a little guy
conservative 911 got him acting out you
know yeah yeah yeah
before i think if you put a little fade
at the loop it might look a little more
natural at the
all right we'll note that
yeah
don't care who it is
are you listening ted cruz are you
listening to santas no are you listening
rubio they're not
are you listening though
no the term skeleton crew
should be a generous application to what
the fbi
is he's popping off he really thinks
he's doing something yeah no he's
popping the [ __ ] off right now
i mean this is this is the revolution
this is it everyone is a liberal okay
it's over uh liberalism is like
completely
completely taken root this is no
different than like this is right wing
aaron sorkin [ __ ] okay that's what this
is this is like
he's he's debating the government out of
existence you know i mean he's debating
federal agencies out of existence he's
like you sir
shall not stand you know what i mean
that's what he's doing
yeah
he's how dare you wing the fbi out of
existence
i love that
great president is through with him this
is not about backing the blue it's not
about guys with guns it's about guys
with pencils it's about buttersoft
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah this is my favorite
he's holding a pen in his hand he's he
literally ha he is the buttersoft [ __ ]
you're sitting at a desk with a pen in
your hand at least like we recognize
we're buttersoft [ __ ] like we make no
mistake on that front we have two mugs
you're at a desk with two [ __ ] mugs
yeah and a pen in your hand we like we
like sitting in front of the computer
and as you're noted his heart is barely
functional yeah okay so that's that that
if you're stand up too fast you'll have
a [ __ ] heart failure he's like these
are not the door knockers you know these
are not the door busters all right these
are the pistol bushes like [ __ ] what do
you mean who went in who went in the
retrieve it wasn't the accountants that
went in to retrieve the material okay
i like my police strong and active i
like them shooting and asking questions
later ain't no desk work
hell no ain't no desk work for these
piansies
yeah
with clip-on ties who are just taking
orders just doing their job well guess
what
i know the people who are having you do
this have promised that they'll kill you
last figuratively
that's never how it works out
so the yeah the extremes the bill
crystals of the world the lincoln
projects i'm the good republican no
you're not you're complicit with evil
and any republican and any host
anyone who claims to put on our team
jersey i'm just cringing this is like
hard doesn't
actively advocate for the dismantling
dismembering
complete restructuring if at all
of all of our intelligence agencies
there is a special place in hell for
people like you it's one thing
to wear did any did anyone reach his
deadline by the way did ted did any he
gave the deadline at 12 o'clock did
anyone advocate for the dismantling of
every intelligence agency uh well
majority titan green or whatever no she
didn't go far enough every intelligence
agency oh true that's right right right
power everything's dismantled
yes yeah i don't know he did rise to
that occasion
catch that smoke too yo yo yo yo bro
what the [ __ ] he tossed the gauntlet and
nobody made that announcement
that's sad for him that's kind of [ __ ]
up i know
let me see i mean if anybody
would have it would have been her right
so let's see if she's calling for no
it's just the fbi that's the most that's
the boldest thing we've heard yeah
conservatives do get results i mean
republicans do follow uh their they they
know what their you know
their audience is except
in this case defunding the fbi would
genuinely present a threat to the
established hierarchy uh considering
that the fbi alongside with all law
enforcement agencies protect capital so
i don't think they're going to do that
any time soon okay
if it was like i don't know uh
jailing like a 14 year old trans girl
from for attending a swim meet in utah
like they would do that easy that's a
that's a gimme you know they'll do that
immediately because that doesn't
threaten the the way things work
um but when it comes down to it like no
one is [ __ ] defunding the fbi brother
that's not happening
i'm with you i'm with you on it i see
you i hear you get ready for
disappointment if that's genuinely
something you believe in yeah and here
is um
he continues on
just to show you how serious he is again
evil it's another to try and link arms
with us and then turn on us
how's that for purity test i'm pissed
this show is going to be
different tenor and tone are you
starting to get the picture on with the
show get ready for now that's what i
call trump in this compilation
this is a serious episode
bro what the [ __ ] is this by the way
he's doing sketch skits yeah he does he
does sketches yeah he's a funny guy i'm
glad he comes out every once in a while
to remind us how what a failed comedian
he is
there's a better match this show's gonna
be a different antenna i'm pissed off
anyway
here's me nearly in blackface
[Music]
yeah it's great that's uh that's i got a
good fall out of that
um
nice goofs and gaffes really hate
musical reference too with the tlc song
from don't go chasing waterfalls yeah i
mean his entire audience is like [ __ ]
78 as well so
obviously that is like the most relevant
recent new thing that they can come up
with that makes sense to me there's one
more great over here from crowder
these people aren't your friend
people [ __ ] about division nope i'm
ready i want a thick dividing line
i really do it's time to start calling
offsides if uh
you're an at-will state and you're an
employer i would fire everybody
fire everybody
who celebrates this awesome hey [ __ ]
notice wait pause first again
notice how he knows his market
he's he's dropped all pretested like uh
you know he has the workers on his side
he knows he's talking to small business
tyrants with like pool cleaning
businesses and hvac businesses you know
what i mean yeah fire all your employees
fire all of them
fire all the libs folks what happened to
the american working class that you were
siding with you dumb [ __ ] what was that
about that was [ __ ] always it's
always [ __ ] that's a good point
maxine waters said harass them wherever
they go and diners and well you know
what don't serve them
oh
don't do business with them okay
interesting how are you going to know
that i'm celebrating the donald trump
raid
like to deny me of my business i'm sure
that all these small businesses are
really excited to eliminate 50 of their
customers for stephen crowder as well i
mean he's like yelling like this but i
think he
i mean i think he's popping off for no
reason right now because it's just not
gonna like no one is gonna do that
no one
bro he already gave a deadline nobody
nobody cared about yeah the man gives
deadlines
uh and finally one finest
final bonus crowder clip
november let's go back in time november
2016 right after the fbi opened its
investigation into hillary's emails days
before the election the second the
second time
let's see how he feels about the fbi
uh at that moment
you know we're not on a daily program so
sometimes by the time this [ __ ]
is wearing a not gay shirt yeah that was
one of his guys i thought that was one
of the cast members
well
what
the what was it like not gay jared or
something i don't [ __ ] know yeah
there's quarter black jared
and then not gay something i don't
[ __ ] know and then there's the asian
lawyer oh i thought he was saying i'm
not gay which you know
is important for him to put out there
because there are questions yeah he's
he's addressing them
we get on the show we go oh my gosh that
was this week oh yeah well we did the
show before that the anthony weiner
scandal and the fbi that all happened
afterwards that keeps on getting the
gift that keeps on giving that all
happened after our last show so if you
of course you all know about it but i
think this is the highlight of the
anthony weiner scandal joe biden was
even caught off guard is this the right
spot dan yeah um
right is the reason why the second
investigation was launched okay right in
an interview live and they brought it up
and this is this is how it feels about
anthony weiner i'd be remiss if i didn't
note that if she had released all the
emails from the get-go we wouldn't be
having this conversation
well that's true brandon i don't know
where this email with his emails came
from what apparently anthony weiner
wilde god how much more
joe biden is in this clip
i should not come in he's young and spry
here huh
it really is crazy to me how quick the
deterioration was because yeah this is
2016 and he's still he's still with it
here he's a young buck
whipper
well you know what that's right nobody
should comment in trouble on anthony
weiner uh no good comes from anthony
weiner no no good comments true i mean
literally no nothing good comes from
anthony weiner uh so this is for those
who don't know fbi reopened the well the
investigation was never closed let's be
clear uh but they found some new emails
on huma's laptop as i've always uh
implied on this show i can substantiate
at zero but i believe that she is
hillary clinton's insatiable lesbian
partner um and uh okay by the way just
want to let the everyone know she's gay
but not me no no he's not he's not how
dare you say that i'm not a woman
quote unquote stephen crowder i'm not
gay yeah
now it may relate to make it sound
consensual i can't imagine
i can't imagine i think i think hillary
can only enjoy
physical intimacy if it's non-consensual
i think you're right i think
is it coming up when he talks with the
fbi well no
this is basically it
the point being that he was not
particularly outraged that uh the fbi
was in the fbi was conducting what is uh
otherwise considered a political act
right not within the 90-day period
which here are some things that the the
republican party has said other than
consistently calling us a banana
republican banana republican banana
republic one of the things that they say
is that the fbi is doing this as a
political action against someone who was
slated to run for president
which is a and it's not an election year
it's the [ __ ] midterms okay and
donald trump is not officially running
for president yet
you cannot claim that the the the
federal authorities are unable to
investigate a private citizen
um uh under those uh under those weird
boundaries that they've set because then
anyone could just be like yeah i'm
running for president actually well and
also again i'm running for president in
the next four years so you can't you
know oh i'm sorry are you are you
officer are you stopping for drunk
driving like the whole thing they were
fine with hillary getting investigated
like five days before the election i
mean i mean yeah they're hypocrites yes
i don't think it's it's just like a
funny but yeah anyway they think that
like this is a secret sauce to like it's
this is the secret words to say they get
out of any sort of like lawyers hate
them judges hate them
use these secret words to get out of any
they're the law and justice people no
one's above the law right i mean what
the [ __ ] you talking about
anyway here's trump as a final little
bonus trying to
he's getting curved by uh mega swimmer
riley gaines
i'm uh watching the garland press
conference on the side right now by the
way yeah he's announcing they're they're
unsealing all the or they're um they're
unsealing the warrant they're going to
rule okay nice oh my god and he also
confirmed that he personally approved
the raid oh wait andrew yang you better
[ __ ] modify that tweet man no i mean
he's he already popped off he got 100k
likes on it so that's his andrew what
now that's the most he's ever gonna
achieve is like you know
likes on twitter so
uh well that'd be interesting to see
what's on the warrant but here is don
the donald uh trying to grab some [ __ ]
let's take a look largest applause i've
ever heard come on up here look at this
i love how he talks about her look at
this i'd love to grab your [ __ ]
oh my god
he's [ __ ] in his pants i mean it's
crazy
look at this
oh man she didn't want any of that
she did not want any of that
this man is such a womanizer he
literally can't help himself
look at this
man i like to snack on you
give me a s it's snack time baby this
was a major l because like they brought
the 17th place losers like you couldn't
get like at least like the fifth place
loser or something to be transphobic
like they want they had like the worst
bottom of the barrel one i didn't know
that that's funny yeah
one more time
look at this
you look like my daughter i like them
you want to know something funny about
this and this is something that like uh
you know i don't know if you're familiar
with the brain rod that is known as
transvestigations
these people who like think every these
transphobic people think like everyone's
actually secretly trans
one of the funniest things that happens
in facebook groups like that is that
they end up thinking that like their
close friends and family are actually
secretly trans
and uh they routinely uh uh say that
like cis women are actually trans right
and it's like if you're jacked and you
don't uh you don't uh uh
abide by like the traditional western
standards like i i just wouldn't be so
rigid about uh gender
because like someone could easily one of
those trans investigators would probably
easily clock you as a trans person
you know what i mean if you're like why
are you doing this you're only cucking
yourselves like ben shapiro
constantly talking about masculinity and
what it means to be a man and you have
to you while sounding the way he does
you know what i mean glass house man
you're literally lollipop guild bro
she jacked
um here is a shout out j.r jackson did a
breakdown of trump getting swerved
look at this
snack time
oh my god okay so we have
grabs creeper's arm to establish
distance so she's a pro she's been in
here
let's see smart
looks no
god he is so disgusting
[Music]
quite a breakdown
he's just copping a peek
just gonna say keep female sports female
yo
she said it
like i said
she said it don't worry you're not it
sounds like she's not going to win any
swim meets regardless no she's not uh
even if it's all cis women you're still
15 16th place so let's listen it doesn't
really matter from the second place
person
not 15th [ __ ] yeah
they had to go down they had to go down
the line to find like the the
transporter person who will become like
the the transphobic representative love
that
oh man she is not having it at all
look at that body language he puts his
hand on her back and she just hobbles
away like she doesn't even want to be
inches next to him
look at that
you people don't add stuff up to me that
way
wow
wow you must have grabbed her ass or
something for her to react that way
she really
something happened back there
look at that just to show you how
ridiculous it is
do we all look like
attempted handshakes
oh man her body was just crazy
yeah i mean she's just
you think he stinks like his breath
stinks and stuff oh i don't know he's
like he's like a very clean person i
think he's like a neat freak or a clean
freak a little bit so maybe not okay
probably smells like really horrible
cologne though i suspect
some that like
like something that just like old people
use and find this isn't the last thing i
have a song and then you know we could
if you want to keep talking about some
you got something you want to discuss
but this is a future sound bite of the
h3 podcast zack i hope you've already
pulled it here it is uh at the cpac
conference they have a segment called
ladies and gentlemen we are all domestic
terrorists
please welcome
ladies and gentlemen we are all domestic
terrorists yes i love that you got that
i love that ladies and gentlemen we are
all domestic terrorists that's true
so true
that's right suits you guys
yeah
so that's it that's all i've got
i mean that's that's so that's wonderful
oh no well there's more like
white-pilled stuff
about the inflation reduction act and
stuff
the inflation production i mean i don't
want to blackpill you on that then if
you're if you're white pulled on it i
mean look it's there's there's some good
in there it's like the bare minimum
well they're offering the size of the
state of michigan every year for further
drilling yeah and that the entire
incentivization structure is is
basically uh
basically tied into offering further
land for uh the oil and gas industry to
drill
so you have to open up that level of uh
no no no we're not we're not gonna
happen on this ladies and gentlemen we
are all domestic that we like
they also took they also took out the uh
the the uh price negotiations for like
the entirety
so it's just for it's just for medicare
and that that only comes into place uh
2026 i think okay and it's only for like
a couple drugs not all okay which is
preposterous um
that wasn't hard here
but that was the only way that you could
but that was the only way that they
could like ever pass it because
uh big pharma was against that to begin
with dude joe manchin is such a shill i
mean he goes yo i'm down for this like
clean energy [ __ ] if you guarantee
massive swaths of land for more
drilling activities yeah kirsten cinema
uh was able to take out the carried
interest loophole
so that was another one wait what
yeah so one of the things that kirsten
cinema did was uh they heard that
loophole they carried interest loophole
is basically just the way for uh hedge
funds
to
um to to further avoid taxes so she did
a good thing
no no no no like the carriage interest
loophole was going to be closed it's
still there
what if dude i cannot believe her yeah
her switch
wow
wow
yeah that's awesome it's a it's a it's a
bonus basically it's like it's a
compensation mechanism for hedge funds
that
directly uh that does not
that does not
uh uh
that does not tax it as though it is a
um because hedge fund compensation
mechanisms revolve around uh a
percentage like tied to your performance
you get a percentage of the you get a
percentage of the entire uh revenue that
you're generating
and instead of taxing that as though
it's income which would be a much higher
percentage to tax they tax that as uh as
as just carried interest
which is
you know
uh yeah so christian semina simner
cinema which is incredible i mean the
woman sold her soul clearly something
happened and joe manchin
who advocated for the drilling thing he
literally owns and is independently
wealthy or not he's wealthy from oil
uh the man joe manchin is cold he's a
cold
guy yeah his family owns a coal mine
dude you're such a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
but the fact that he's on the energy
committee is like that's a clear
conflict of interest but you know no one
will no one will address that i guess so
is there anything else you want to black
fill me on
here here's the here's good stuff and
you can tell me why it sucks
businesses get incentives for a
deployment of lower carbon and carbon
free energy sources
oh yeah no that's that's uh good i mean
okay i don't think that like positive
incentivization alone is going to
i i think we need a stick
like this is all parrots we need both
yeah there's not there's no stakes in
this one it's just all carrots right
right right
yeah the sticks and even the carrots are
tied to uh just giveaways to the oil and
gas industry okay so so lukewarm
medicare can negotiate lower prices
you're explained why this one is uh
black right i mean it takes it's not
enacted it's not enacted until 2016 and
it doesn't cover all yeah drugs right
okay bernie sanders actually had a
really good provision in the vote-a-rama
that of course was immediately cast
aside
where he wanted to tie medicare and
medicaid price negotiations to the va
because the va already is allowed va is
the only government body that's allowed
to do uh
price negotiations on pharmaceuticals
um and and well medicaid and medicare is
also the same government but medicare
and medicaid are not allowed to do that
this will allow medicare to do that
um but uh i i'm not entirely certain if
they will be able to lock at the va
prices how the [ __ ] is there even a law
that says you cannot negotiate the price
of them
i wonder why [ __ ]
that's i wonder why america is the only
country
i wonder why america is the only country
that won't allow that actually we have a
law
that says you cannot
question the price
yeah that i charge for anything yeah
good i mean what the [ __ ] wholesale
prices exist in every facet of our lives
except for when the government is
purchasing medication in bulk it's so
[ __ ] up um and even though every other
country is able to do that so they could
set the prices to any [ __ ] thing they
want they can't negotiate that's called
inelastic demand yes you could
technically price it at whatever the
[ __ ] you want and people would die
without it so they will pay whatever the
[ __ ] they can well the gov we will do
taxes yeah
wow dude
um consumers and businesses get
incentives to make cleaner energy
choices okay
loving that
hating are we loving that
some fossil fuel production on public
lands would be bolstered we thought
about that
we needed that we needed that big time
more more drilling
um moving on
uh
we've got the new program
boosts investment in climate
do we love that
yeah that's good i mean okay good just
just testing you i'm in favor of uh look
i'm in favor of increasing uh you know
increasing public funding or rather
shifting our resources away from fossil
fuels to renewable energy okay that's
definitely something that we should have
been doing many many years ago already
okay dubs cost
increase for fossil fuel production on
public lands costs increase for fuel
production on public lands do we like
that i mean it sounds good but
we'll see ladies and gentlemen we are
all domestic terrorists
medicare drug costs can be capped we
love that right yeah for two thousand
dollars that's a little insanely high
but it's good better people enrolled in
aca
plans get an extension on premium
assistance
love it or leave it
um
not i don't have an opinion on that one
and we are all domestic terrorists
uh this is the worst one by far the irs
gets a funding boost 87 000 new
employees for the irs baby
most of that is going to be so the irs
currently still uses floppy disks like
they're still using technology from like
the [ __ ] moon landing that's not a
joke yeah no i believe you i'm so uh a
lot of that is just to to modernize the
irs and to make sure that there's like
people on the [ __ ] line when you call
the irs
that sounds horrible people are making
it seem like they're getting like armed
guards to go and like kill republicans
where do they pull that number from when
they say like 65 000 new irs agents or
something
um i think it's that's just what the irs
is uh talked about what they plan to
hire
so that is a real figure but you know
the irs has been like critically
underfunded for for many many years and
well if you guys didn't know the irs is
actually where
we get our money from you know that's
crazy uh by the way there's the the 87
000 uh new irs agents or the way that
they're mentioning that is not like that
number isn't uh real
it's not going to be it's not going to
be exactly 87 000.
a lot of the funding is going to go
directly to um the the 78 billion for
the irs is going to be phased in over 10
years and it's actually going to
it's actually what the [ __ ] i'm sorry
bro
somebody crunched the numbers on the
dome number calculation obviously not as
exact as they measured but lined up when
i saw damage or heard them say hassan's
head breath tiny fraction under six
inches on the smaller side
hassan's head length on the smaller side
38th percentile
bro
it says assange by deltoid breath
99th percentile
yeah in conclusion
hassan has a smaller head
and wider shoulders than most males god
damn it
i don't agree with that mystery is one
thing i don't believe in science
yeah i don't i don't agree yes i do not
agree with skull science
i can say that unless we're talking
about cops
of course let's talk about cop for
knowledge
their shoulders really [ __ ] you over the
wife yeah
if i had normal shoulders my head would
not appear right
so does that mean i have a little bit of
a smaller dome too i guess so
hmm
because
i thought we knew that already
yeah but i so i'm on the smaller side of
this one and then my
length was shorter than yours yeah and
you're in the 37 i'm i've got a tiny
dome
wow interesting apparently huh a small
salt small small small dome
but you have those slight shoulders so
it kind of balances out yeah
you have the shoulder advantage i'm
saying you're proportional i'm just
kidding
you called my shoulder slight yeah
you just call me a dainty little fanboy
you got beautiful bad boy
you got beautiful fanboy shoulders
nothing nothing wrong with that yeah
wear it proudly uh so
yeah i don't get the hysteria over the
irs agents because
i think that's great that tax evaders
are gonna have to [ __ ] pay taxes my
taxes are clean as a whistle
come out at me i don't give a [ __ ]
but
you know
that's good i like that people are gonna
have to pay taxes and furthermore
the the tax system in this country is so
unbelievably [ __ ] let's modernize it
we love that yeah
um you know normal countries civilized
nations uh actually file your taxes for
you and then send you a receipt in the
end of the year that sounds so [ __ ]
nice how is that yeah that communism it
doesn't make sense like they already
know how much you owe them because if
you don't pay them enough government
they're like you didn't pay us enough
money so it's like well why the [ __ ] did
you make money i don't know maybe
because there's a multiple billion
dollar industry uh that that has a very
fat lobbying arm h r block and yeah and
turbo tax are quite literally the reason
why uh there is now a middle manager
here that is a necessity
to to file your taxes for free which by
the way of course they don't even
[ __ ] file it for free
they try to dupe you into they take up
paying them
and then uh that's the reason why there
was actually a class action lawsuit
where they had to pay out 140 million
dollars recently wow for lying to people
and not providing them with free uh
free taxes
uh i think it was turbo tax oh terrible
one one of those guys
um they also routinely mismanage your
information
well they also sell it
but then sometimes they also uh
accidentally leak it yeah it's a
wonderful process and it's got all of
them does not exist but that's just
america every part of our lives is
dominated by the private public
partnership where private corporations
trying to milk the government for as
much money as they possibly can to offer
you like the absolute [ __ ] worst
job for a job that could very easily be
handled by the government and has been
handled by other governments uh
throughout time
so what america in a country without
you know with like uh streamlined taxes
do they even have accountants is that
even a profession in other countries
yeah of course you still need to have
like accountants for your business and
whatnot i'm sure but
like but yeah tax accounting and [ __ ]
yeah that's a huge feel like i get if
you're a big corporation and stuff yeah
i mean i i don't know but i i'm i know
that they have accountants in other
countries yes like if you're just a dude
yeah okay but if you're just like a dude
normal guy normal job normal income you
don't need a [ __ ] accountant
if you're in
no normal yeah i don't think you would
need that yeah love love you're using
sweden
you they just send you a bill love
um yep and you just confirm it yeah
okay so they send you a bill and you can
contest it like yo i don't get this
number that's disgusting no it's
communism i hate that
no you don't get to contest it
i mean there's no reason for it because
it's always right
yeah and depending on how much you make
you get a little bit money back the next
year
and uh yeah it's super easy so let me
ask you this do they
they take the money out of your checks
so they just tell you at the end of the
year this is how much you paid in taxes
and just how much you made
right you estimate how much you're gonna
make the year okay
at the start of the year
and then you get if you if you make more
you're going to get
to pay a little bit more taxes i guess
and if you make less you're going to pay
less taxes and you get back so so they
they pull from your um paycheck based on
your estimate at the beginning of the
year
well
i guess it's a little bit more
complicated than that i'm not exactly
sure how it's worked how it works
because it's so easy that's how we file
taxes if you're filing a 1099 you're
making an estimation on what your
revenue is gonna be for the year if you
file it quarterly right right and then
they they offer they they
penalize you for what you went uh under
or how much you went under like i send
prepayments every year
yeah so that's like it's kind of like
that i guess
ladies and gentlemen we are all domestic
terrorists
abolish the irs
it's like how are you going to build
roads i don't know shut the [ __ ] up
anything else
i mean that's that's good i have to pee
really bad yeah i do too i can't believe
it
guys what a joy what a pleasure it's the
leftovers underground hundreds of feet
you'll never find us don't try yeah well
this is also
i mean taxpayer funded
at this point yeah we got
re-appropriated fema facility that you
the taxpayers funded thank you for your
service patriots
we have
we have at this point hundreds of boston
dynamic dogs strapped with uh m14 so
please oh yeah
nc4 let's see good measure they suicide
bomb you yeah they will do that
all right thanks for watching everybody
oh come on
i was gonna i was gonna [ __ ] do that
you look good
so anyway
ladies and gentlemen we are all domestic
terrorists
[Music]